next question if you had to live as one
of your characters for the rest of your
life who would you choose I'd probably
choose the character of Seth Rogen's
from this is the end because it's kind
of me ah oh no no guys this is a family
website
oh hi dear help me here hold this in
your mouth yes thank you
great Oh No you ripped in half
the first question is go Bubbe one of
the funniest encounter you've had with a
fan I've had a few I've had a lot of
people yell at me because I won't admit
I'm Zach Galifianakis I had a guy in
Shake Shack come up to me the other day
and say whoa are you Seth Rogen and I
said yeah he said no you're not and I
said yeah I am and he said how tall are
you I said around 6 feet anyway okay you
are Stephanie hi guys hi oh hi of all
your movies which one are you most proud
of I'm really proud of sausage already
honestly I've been working on it for
like ten years and I think it's very
unique and funny next question
I even have anything new yet how high
were you when you wrote sausage party
varying degrees of highness did anyone
saw him to the movie and then later back
out after realizing the movie's full
story like that never happened but what
did happen is Puff Daddy was pretty into
being in the movie at one point and then
found out it was an animated movie and
not a live-action movie where we all are
dressed like food and that made him lose
interest very fast would you rather have
a pizza slice four feet or cupcakes for
hands you can eat them and they'll grow
back pizza feet
can we oh hi can we expect a remake of
the Kim and Kanye video but with you is
Kanye no we can't I'm a Kim Min if you
could play any Disney character and a
lot of live action adaptation who would
you choose Ursula from The Little
Mermaid love that woman great character
strong female character as well and so
as a man I would like to take that what
are some tips you would give someone to
laugh like Seth Rogen I don't know just
lead a very unhealthy lifestyle yeah my
shoelace go for it's just Burberry
that's it
mm-hmm oh yeah yummy huh
[Music]
the first thing I do is I go to my mum's
house and just lay on her bed and tell
her what I want to eat and stay there
for like three three days maybe just
with my family and my friends come and
visit and I just I haven't been home for
so long that I just I think that's what
I miss most my house definitely Zach
did Wayne is just he's such a gentleman
so well-behaved and and just really
really nice and back well we all would
hang out in somebody's one of their
trailers and just like order food and it
was it was they're completely different
people but both so sweet and just really
nice
[Music]
I do intend to I don't know whether
it'll be a Hindi film or an English
movie yet I just know that I'm in the
middle of assessing films from both here
and there I'll definitely be doing a
movie I just know which one it will be
the one advice that has stuck to me for
a very long time as live-and-let-live we
always we always have an opinion on what
someone is doing and why they're doing
it and they should be doing you know
they shouldn't be doing it and who is
anyone to say what anyone else should do
so live and let live I love that don't
try and be like me and trying to be like
you I always wanted to be Priyanka when
I grew up I just I still don't know who
that is but it'll take your lifetime to
figure out who you are you know you just
have to every single day identify what
you like and what you don't who you are
and what your opinion is and don't let
anyone tell you that you know you're not
your dreams are not worth something or
you can't be a certain way because you
can be whatever you decide to be and
there are too many girls in the world
who are always told that they should
behave a certain way or be a certain way
and that's not we should all try and be
how we want right
adopt a puppy great thing to get a puppy
because my dog is a cocker spaniel and
he's back home in Mumbai with my mom and
I really really missed him but he's
really old he can't travel now he's like
lost one man down man down yeah so that
that's definitely something I've been
I've been wanting to do for a while so
this is just really appropriate for my V
is that deep on bachelor I mean you're
welcome
[Music]
don't do it no I'm skinny wow what would
I tell myself keep my mouth shut I'll
hit more often that did the first season
I was a little too opinionated probably
that's just who I am
it's just kind of getting used to each
other and in some ways you know Vanessa
and I have for the most part I've been
living with each other and that's
obviously a big step in any relationship
you know we've certainly been fast
tracking it from the very time we've met
and so that certainly has a lot of great
excitement and also there's a lot of
like okay this is this is really
something no wedding plans yet again you
know Vanessa and I we're taking things
really slow and we're happy to do that
we've known each other for less than a
year now bachelor nation has a bit of a
back lock with an engaged couple so
there's a plenty of couples in line for
us that have to tie the knot before we
do so this guy is this like loving life
you know when you find a good spot on a
couch you don't move you know I'm
someone who kind of wears like I'm
nostalgic I just kept it on as a kind of
a memento or a reminder to me of like
this this process potentially working
out no no not really
my opinion of Corinne definitely kind of
changed over the course the season while
filming but she was someone I even had a
hard time figuring out and I think kind
of America's opinion of Corinne and that
hot in the evolution was kind of one was
similar to mine
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it sucked it it was heartbreaking
but the same time I knew anding Kaitlyn
for about eight weeks you get over the
same way you kind of get into it like
it's rapid-fire and these emotions once
you remove yourself from that
environment you know while it's not easy
it's probably goes quicker than say
someone who broke up with someone
after a two-year relationship or
something like that
[Music]
it couldn't be more fun and it's also
incredibly exhilarating to when you get
done with the dance you're like that was
amazing you don't think about the fact
that it's live and millions of people be
watching it that doesn't even cross your
mind it's just the fact that you're in
this big arena and it's filled with
people screaming and cheering and you're
about to do something you don't even
know what you're about to do and you
barely know your steps
I'm not a big planner so I don't even
know what I'm doing next week so five
years who the heck knows I don't see
myself doing much reality TV after this
you know Vanessa and I obviously are
gonna focus on a relationship and work
on that and I have been lucky enough to
start my own business which will be
launching shortly it's just a men's
grooming line called the polish gent
that's gonna be my my number one
priority outside of the relationship
with Vanessa and hopefully that takes up
most of my time these cute little
puppies are from Michaelson found
animals adopted shop I have all the
puppies
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
No
so our records since take this to your
grave have gone color palette blue and
then red and blue in the red and I think
that when you first played young in
Venice for me it just felt like it was
maybe that song felt especially purple
to me it felt like a left turn
[Music]
yeah no one's ever brought me a puppy
yet don't get the questions you want say
it's your sons
[Music]
I think it would be great it's just
really agreeing on the songs or creating
cool original songs we have one
Christmas issue type of song holiday-ish
types on but it was recorded a long time
ago this is a very focused interview
[Music]
I have never talked to Bruno about it I
think he explained the picture and the
explanation like caused a little bit of
the magic out of it possibly he's like
just like he was surprised to see a
pop-up photographer bump him or
something yeah um go down it's like a
slide
[Laughter]
[Music]
so yeah the new sound I don't know that
there is a new sound you know it's just
every song is gonna be a different thing
and and that's something the record is
not gonna sound like you have a minute
no and I mean that's the thing is it's
not a style you know like that's I don't
think we've for a long time I don't
think we've been very easy to you know
if we wrote a song that sounded too
specifically like a style you know we we
don't really use it so tell me about the
song whisper sweet nothings in my ear I
don't know I think I answered it I got
lost in puppy I think that it like when
something is like disruptive and
interesting and and counterintuitive
it's interesting but then when it
becomes the thing that's expected yeah
like it's harder to that's what it's
like I don't know so I didn't want it to
be a gimmick yeah it was the thing that
we did naturally and then when it
started to be the thing that people
commented on all the time it's like well
we gotta go through that anymore ah
belly rubs belly rubs hi
we get so many One Tree Hill questions
it's it's really funny because like
because that was like maybe what you did
it for a minute but but in general it
was a very you know it was like maybe a
few days out of our entire life you know
so like it's funny how often I get asked
about that I mean it was awesome it was
really fun
[Applause]
I've answered this one before I think
but I mean but not with puppies that's
true but now they're safe I would do it
if we can attach the right director you
know we're in we can get this project
move you know really that's all tied up
with the aliens is franchise a lien
stuff you know originally it was looking
good but I mean I'm gonna be like really
rude imma be gravely honest not in front
of the puppies pay it it's it's
interesting to try and be like when
you're in a band from I think gonna ban
for like for 15 years and in some places
we've played this city 20-plus times and
you're playing in an arena where there's
like some hardcore fans and there's like
hardcore fans from from ten years ago
and you know like and so it's like quite
a task to try and do put a setlist
together that's gonna please everybody
but at the same time I think that the
thing that we've all said that we wanted
to do more and be better about is like
kind of rotating songs a little bit good
answer look at that do it again buddy
you can do it
probably not it was expensive and this
is one of those things that's super
funny that no one knew about is we had
wire work in that video all of it got
cut but it cost like a house it was so
crazy I can't believe we wasted money on
it and like and it didn't even work it
looked really stupid it's one of those
things my work made it
well like there are some things that
like it's more funny to or more
interesting again to probably like think
about what it would be like but if we
actually did that video people would
talk if it's like it would not be great
yeah the sequel video to that I don't
know if that would work so hard
playing for President Obama's inaugural
ball crazy awesome that was that was a
thing that like you know they'll tell
grandkids about that that's pretty wild
I thought you were first I could were
saying that Obama will tell his
grandkids you know you'll never believe
that one time never great
so the first record and take this your
grade was really fun and really awesome
I'm really proud of it but that was us
like we were still learning how to be a
band and we weren't really very
ambitious about it I mean like I think
you know all of us were like yeah we'll
do this for this would be a really
awesome thing to do while we're on you
know a semester off from school and then
and then dance dance was the first song
to me where we kind of were our own band
we weren't really trying to be anybody
else we were kind of you know when
people asked me every record every song
we put out there's always the you know
what's with the new sound you know and
that's been for like you know 12 years
of follow-up records that people been
asking that and I think the start of
that is dance dance
I would love to break down the thing of
like of like bands being special right
like that was a thing that we that's
where we came from you know when we were
playing in Parker bands too like in
these and he's like you know don't be
dive bars and things like that like
there really wasn't any separation
between audience and band except for
that the band had guitars and whatever
and then something happened where like
it became this thing of like you sign
autographs and you take pictures and
stuff which is awesome and I'm happy to
do that but it was it it was a weird
thing it's always been a weird thing to
me that that that's a thing that
separates you you're not you're not part
of the audience anymore I don't like
that I miss that
in the early 2000s were one big fashion
regret for me it's one thing to like hat
like everyone does crazy fashion stuff
but to do it on like the cover of
Rolling Stone yeah wow it's really hard
to focus when there's like baby animals
around I've feel like we kind of
answered a couple questions but like
didn't really answer them yeah these
guys are all adoptable and you can adopt
them at North Shore Animal League
America congratulations
hey friend why don't you join us thank
you okay okay goodbye
[Music]
I had a very interesting time stirring
on a reality show at only the age of
eight but um I don't think I would ever
do one ever again just because they're a
little stressful and I rather do acne
I think a transition from dance into
acting is different and the same in so
many ways because when you dance you
have to act and you have to show emotion
so I think it really helped me really
into acting
it's pretty obvious I have the biggest
crush on Zac Efron I've had it since I
was five years old and I will always
love him till the day I die I wish I
could marry him but he's slightly too
old for me
I would say zendaya is a really big
inspiration for me in the fashion world
just because she has so many amazing
looks and it's different every time
sometimes she decides to go more on the
tomboy route or sometimes she decides to
make it super girly and glamorous so
she's definitely a very big inspiration
to me
I had no clue that Chandler would blow
up let alone have over a billion views
and it was probably the best experience
and day of my life when that video
released just because ever since then
it's just been a whirlwind for me to
make sure I loved everything that I'm
doing and to always remember that I am
still a child and to never take anything
too far so that I'm not overworked
[Music]
she plays really old music and she'll
dress up and show impersonate all of my
dances that I did when I used to compete
she was the biggest fan of Dance Moms
and she knows more of it than I do
so it's really really funny
less is more when you're wearing too
much makeup I feel like you can look
cakey
[Music]
oh it's okay you can eat your hair and I
don't know exactly what I'll be doing in
20 years I think I would love to
continue acting and dancing maybe
choreograph some things do a lot more
music videos to see and continue to
feature and a bunch of films
[Music]
what did you do that I can't even deal
with this
[Music]
hi Miranda Lambert today I'm doing an
interview with rescue puppies as you can
see they're all up for adoption by the
way my dogs succeed a lot of interesting
things the very only Louis Vuitton purse
I ever owned was given to me and it lost
his handles really quickly so I gave up
on not things my dogs are more important
Finnick not thinking about realized hi
collaborate with another artist there's
a lot I think
but let me huge fan and Beyonce's
probably every girl's answer would be to
say my favorite mixed drinks is
Tito's vodka and Lacroix
[Music]
I don't have a favorite song or album
because they're all my babies they're
like my dogs but I really enjoyed the
process of this last record I did called
the way to these wings because I took my
thumb on it and spent over a year riding
for it and I really got to sort of
explore my songwriting in a different
way than I ever had before I'm a huge
audio slate fans I'd say that was pretty
different than the rest of the stuff on
my iPod old-school
favorite place to eat in Nashville it's
actually a bar it's called winners have
winners and losers those are my hangout
spots in Midtown but they have delicious
chicken tenders and awesome stuff real
this inspired me to start it my passion
for dogs and rescue dogs and mutts if
you are not a dog lover yet you should
become one and I would say adopt don't
shop love a shelter pets one has some
copy boobs like regular dog food but
it's smaller and it comes from a cuter
butt so hard to answer questions while
these dogs are here
[Music]
when will was there was my first year so
I was still trying to figure out where
the bathrooms were yeah you didn't I
usually always just when where I stood
guys please
[Music]
I learned that Amy loves reading Paul
really any give me a pop I can get it
based on life my love line success
failure these are your kids the middle
of your palm talks about what you want
the top of your hand talks about like
that it's a little obnoxious
I learned that will will drives one of
those recumbent bikes to work
he likes to lean back that's how he gets
everywhere with a flag arm workout yeah
yeah
it takes a really long time to get to
set and you've got a few accidents
[Music]
I just feel like she don't know well she
knows a little bit in the arms body
would do but he is the size but he has a
size he might get it Bertinelli hurt
like water like mice and men
[Music]
I think they did the best ice and the
year before would just be confessing
yeah
[Music]
did you ever bring your childhood kids
home a puppy I did and then I had to
take it away like an hour later it turns
out they didn't deserve it
[Music]
[Music]
this is an aqueduct you're there close
up they're making out there making out
I guess it's when you try to yeah that's
an awkward moment do that and your
co-star is not ready for it right when
you go to kiss down and then you after a
couple kisses provide a custom in the
private area which is what just happened
this is these two puppies re-enacting a
scene that will and I did I got cut for
time it didn't test well
[Music]
wish I hadn't gone back for the last
season of ER you had gone back know that
I have because I had a gray run as dr.
Peter Willoughby and they asked me to
come back for one more season it was
done these this is our director and
assistant director they all have any
creative differences but it always comes
out great
[Music]
ah sure what would I do I'd probably get
on the subway and just man spread as
much as I could I think of so many seats
if I were a me I would love to buy an
economy ticket on any airline and
pretend like it was a king-sized bed I
get concentrate they stupid ape up
easier miss do you run a pet store down
yeah I don't know let me think about
some
the pet store now with puppies running
around Ron Burgundy is on his sailboat
right now
[Music]
you two were embarrassing me
you're embarrassing your mother nope not
on camera that's what I want to give you
a piece of advice stuff gets on the
internet and it doesn't go away you hear
me this is actually very salient
addressed
[Music]
hi my name is Kate McKinnon I'm here
with BuzzFeed I'm going to answer some
fan questions about the upcoming
animated film leap and some other stuff
and you're gonna play with puppies while
I do over here I'm cool and your name
will be Griffith I'm you know tough to
answer questions while there is such
sweetness and unbounded
[Music]
I have had only positive interactions in
relation to my impressions of people
which makes me happy because I do them
with love and I hope that the people of
Hawaii do them of really like them isn't
that right Angela
[Music]
you know it's really fun just running
around backstage when everyone's getting
changed and down feels like a middle
school play all over again sometimes you
see someone naked
[Music]
the trick is I guess fear you don't want
to like ruin it by laughing so but I
often do only haven't spoken much John
what what is it like being is so cute
that you should be eating is it hard
knowing that you should be eating that
because you're so cute
I think my Emmy award has run away to
another continent because I have not
heard from him or her in months oh you
don't like that jacket you think that's
a bad fashion choice let's see if we
could you please jacket I am a cool dude
my name is Rachel look at what a cool
blue that I am
you've gotta believe in yourself and you
just have to work harder at it and
you've ever worked at anything before in
your life and you can keep doing that
and keep believing in yourself great
things that do happen you just have to
work super hard and just um if you have
a passion that's the most beautiful
thing in life and you just have to bust
out and do it baby
my passion used to be comedy but now it
is these four puppies exports
[Music]
can we have lunch please can we stop and
eat we never eat have you noticed that
we're working our way through more
working - yep do their mouths smell like
garbage
yep do you what do I want Ben to kiss me
on the mouth
[Music]
that's an interesting question there is
no backstory I just like to salute and I
guess it became a thing Oh
[Music]
my son Nino who I hope is not watching
this because he would not like to see me
wanting Overson he's doing very well
even though it's very hot in the summer
and he doesn't love that
[Music]
before ten minutes ago it might have
been something different but now it is
swimming in her do you want to read the
question Rachel
[Music]
using this you know the only regression
he's cute but he doesn't have a future
as a professional interviewer
[Music]
I think you know sometimes you don't get
to hello you don't get to hello
oh you want to play fetch you're not in
the room with the people that you're
acting against and sometimes you've done
your parts on different days you wanna
do you wanna um crisabel your Rufus so
sometimes you don't get to see or who
you're acting against
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness Maddie Ziegler is the
most amazing dancer I've ever seen and
I'm so obsessed with her I was obsessed
with her even before she did her first
SIA video what are you eating
and so yes
Baker Rachel I was so excited that she
was doing this because she's I'm I'm so
obsessed with her as an artist and she's
so young and it's crazy that she's so
such an amazing innovate or will you do
me a favor Rachel I just go into my
pocket
and live in my house how was that Sam
he's just in conclusion all of these
fabulous little puppies are adoptable at
North Shore Animal League America which
happens to be where I got myself Nina
from and all of my childhood gets as
well
it's an incredible facility thank you so
much for lending me these friends and
would someone please take them into
their homes because Nina would get too
jealous me and Kate just hanging out
look at that face hi I'm Liam Payne and
I'm here at BuzzFeed and I am about to
meet a lot of puppies
[Music]
hello and you also want to join me
this one really likes me I've got an
attachment here alright then
to some questions
I think I would collaborate best with
Zayn because we do really similar type
of music and I would say that I would
like a music video for you right here
with these puppies because this is just
too much fun right now there's talk of
maybe doing a collaboration maybe I'm
gonna collaborate with this guy right
here and but I can't tell you it is yet
but she is an artist okay
it's very open isn't it I love the
question Beaulieu you why do you want to
pick me a question you will
well I questioned to follow up with that
question I would collaborate with Nicki
Minaj I think the best
my favorite part about touring with the
boys was when we were younger we used to
spend a lot of time together on the tour
bus when we did our first American tour
we had a really tiny small bus it was
just a lot of fun and just hanging out
and it was like I don't know that was
the time when we got to know each of the
best I think throughout the band
[Music]
no I'm not at all I think honestly he's
really really suited for the job and I
know he's really good at what he does
and I wanted to congratulate him - a
massive moment like being in a
Christopher Nolan action film like how
amazing super cool I haven't seen it yet
but I am planning on having a little
event with my team and some of my family
and going down and all of us watching it
together because I want to make sure
that it's in a nice setting I want to go
have amazing cinema and ages and I'd
like I like her to the cinema
you haven't said hello very much I know
the last text message Ison is check the
vids aha so one of my friends because I
was doing some city videos on Instagram
I was longer boring but was in the
operatic slightly you make sure you stay
there the whole time you're just quite
chill what's your deal peep you Evernote
you the naughty one of the bunch to me
[Music]
yes I think we will reunite at some
point in the future I'm sure we have to
I mean we've got an album that we
haven't even told you and I want to
write some more songs as well with the
boys the songwriting process has been a
lot different because you have to look a
lot inside yourself for inspiration it
was different when you were right I was
writing for the boys because you know we
are you have to have for people to play
so in a way it's quite easier as well
but it's hard because I know it's very
very it just relies on you out there
which is nice
and there's some really personal songs
I've done on that album and there's some
that are done by other writers because
there are obviously great writers in the
world and I've got to work with some
great people like Pharrell and Ryan
Taylor and obviously Zedd at the moment
which has been great so I've been really
lucky with the people I got to work with
[Music]
yes there and no there's loads of
different parts to album so I'll
probably please
if so tames um yeah and there's some
ballads there's some hip hop songs
there's some more dance music so I think
there's a really very mix of different
things that we have I don't know how I'm
ever gonna separate from you ever again
look at your eyes my go-to karaoke song
would be I know and now hot lime Linga
Hey but that can only mean one thing
[Music]
there's actually a name for this and
it's a long something-or-other phobia
that yeah they're called I'm not sure
but I'm no longer afraid of spoons
my favorite songs
I think I'd like to go in and play
arenas I love a big stage and I like
running around actually measured it one
time when real on stage we used to do
like six kilometers a night every time
so I'm so used to running around a big
stage so I don't know how I feel going
back to smile do you like it smaller
than usually likes nice and intimate but
I love to do like a really big shows and
I want to go on a great show for you
guys loads different elements in it so I
would wake up at around 9 go to the gym
for a little bit I'd sit and watch I'd
have the new series of peaky blinders
out now that'd be a good day I'm having
to wait for ages I would have an
in-n-out burger because they are the
best thing known to man and that would
be quite a perfect day oh you're back
again
hello my favorite memory was when we
first did Madison Square Gardens we
popped out the floor
and the crowd is just a tall wherever
you go in we popped out the floor it was
just the most amazing feeling ever
knowing that we were in Madison Square
Gardens and our album we just broke the
record for debuting at number one on the
American charts so that was a real fond
memory of mine
how we doing Pete what's hang in
I would say having my missus iron me is
always a nice thing selector and she's
always there I've always got my own her
I would say Pete at this moment in time
is just fulfilling life for me I want to
say thank you to buzz fever have me
today but I just wanted to let everybody
know that all these puppies are
adoptable from the North Shore Animal
League in America so please if you have
a good home and you want a nice lovely
puppy like Pete go and get him
these are the ones that like each other
before don't like you today hey guys
it's Kylie and Jordan and we're here
answering some of your fan questions
with puppies the show is pretty much a
long snapchat story it's just really a
different side of us more personal side
and I'm just excited for people to see
that honestly I can't even think with
this cuteness going on me and Jordan met
through mutual friends one day I got a
phone call from one of my friends and
they're like yeah come over to Kylie's
house we all want to hang out I'm like
and she put her name in my phone and we
just got closer and closer throughout
the years and realized all we need is
each other and and you'll get an out
about now or our only friend
[Music]
I don't know we used to Segway
everywhere I mean everywhere when we
didn't have our license like we would
Segway outside the community to like
miles and miles to the mall probably
turning 21 like that's fun you know I
never had a drink before you want to
know what it's like I'm gonna say Kim I
feel like I go to different sisters for
different problems and right now me and
Kim have just been relating a lot and
talking it honestly it changes every day
so tomorrow it'll pop he's somebody new
but Kim right now is my fave well I
think Kendall would be mad at me if I
didn't say Kendall so I'm gonna what do
you think amusement-park gonna [ __ ] me
really everything I can't do so I would
love to just go have lunch
maybe shop this is not okay because you
know how I am with puppies I think I'm
gonna should we take all of them like I
really am gonna go get a puppy right now
all night I love Bill Nye the Science
Guy for real he is sexy
I tell you it's very daddy am too but if
I had to say someone else probably yeah
it's only bill that we tried to take a
picture with him once I saw him walking
down the street and he said no I totally
understand
when you just want to say no but like we
were really excited Kendall's killing it
Bella Hadid
just killing it can just pretty much
like my friends and family I look for me
I just I find my style and both of my
random things like people walking down
the street or anyone on Instagram where
I'm like oh they're cool I'm I want to
wear my thing like this too or I
wouldn't say there's one person in
particular for me I literally read crazy
things about me like all day every day
so I can't really think of anything
specifically but probably just that like
I am getting married all the time or I
don't know just I read too many things I
can't keep track
this isn't fair they like this dress
they really think my dress I think it's
maybe because she and cozy
I got extensions lash extensions and
moisturizer I cannot live without lotion
I can't live without lipstick if I
forget the lipstick at home it's the one
thing I will turn around I'm sorry I
know you want to leave but he makes so
much noise
I would always overlined my lips when I
was like 16 and all my fans would be
like what color are you wearing that's
all my comments section would say like
what lipstick color are you wearing so I
just thought why not make my own reality
shows I really only watch keeping up or
life of Kylie has kept me entertained
I do been binge watch a lot of other
shows like Handmaid's Tale I'm always
trying to find new shows
I really try hard to take my makeup
completely off like I need to get every
inch of my face I need to clean my
lashes I put on sunscreen every morning
I can't wear a lot of moisturizer
because it breaks my face out
unfortunately I don't know what people
think about us cuz I tend to not look at
it just a lot if you love it all wrong
sometimes I think they have it almost
everything wrong everything except for
you eleven cosmetics
[Music]
it was pretty deep but there wasn't a
lot of waves and Kim kind of threw a
tantrum like immediately when she found
out that she lost it and I was like no
this is fine I went under there and it
was saltwater so it kind of hurt to open
my eyes but I just opened my eyes and
looked around and I saw something
shining swam all the way down there was
like ten feet picked it up and it was
the shining diamond it would I literally
found it in two minutes I think you have
a future career and then I was she was
like I have just you know I don't have
my backing but it's fine I can always
get that and I was like I'm just gonna
look but I went back down I found the
backing
I found the earring backing she was like
you are just future career I'm telling
you diamond finder dive team this was
one of the best interviews I hope we
weren't too distracted but thanks for
sticking through it oh it's perfect and
I see I'm too distracted all right it's
been a real and now
you've been flooding to get in the Sun
so far all the time P buddy you just
remind me of a puppy I wanted in a
headstrong time split up you go over
here you go over here I want to be a
great dad what's her name
Starr and Stella get up on in here there
we go yes
the thing I miss most about being a band
with my brothers is just the traveling
aspect of it now they were with me every
step of the way we got to see amazing
places in the world together and it was
a beautiful time in our lives come back
to me knowing that people having sex in
my music is the best thing in the world
I just require a commission by way of
naming the child after me Nicholas Nick
Nicky Nicolette this should be the
exchange what inspired me to write it
this little guy obviously I would
inspires me to write it was that oh yeah
you know this I can't focus and it's
happening so I was at Coachella actually
hey plain ice was at a rave tent and
what yeah thank you hmm got in there
basically it was very inspiring and
every song I've ever written in my
career is jealous really important song
for me when I broke off solo it's
captured a moment in time for me what do
you think what's your favorite song the
written in your career growing up in a
house full of guys my mom's very strong
woman she had a lot of boys around all
the time
I need you to us we were a handful I
imagine when we all left the nest that's
what it felt like for her they gotta be
honest trustworthy and a dog person not
a cat person today I'm not gonna have a
cat it's fine because the fur dogs
there's one right in front of you
there you go my best piece of dating
advice is be upfront be honest even if
at times it's not always exactly what
you think the person wants to hear
always the truth is better than being
dishonest or not being upfront right
right there's a little bit of healthy
competition going on between my brother
and I but I am The Godfather of Mike one
of my nieces and I did wear a pinstripe
suit to her dedication so I'm fully The
Godfather the best part about it is you
get to play with them and hang out with
them but then you get to have a full
night's sleep ultimate cheat meal pizza
every time or cheeseburger or bacon
cheese burger a burger pizza smash them
together right
skaara can you get out you can't get out
I do watch Game of Thrones I have many
favorite characters but every time I'd
like a character they get killed so I
have to know if I like a character not
say who I like because I just die right
away
Joe has never given me a wedgie that's a
lie
straight line straight from his mouth
he's full of [ __ ] tell him I said so do
it
rip the set down eat it you know lots of
memorable moments from a Disney days we
used to do the Disney Channel Games
which was a good time they would collect
all of us from the different shows and
then put us together at Disney World
really it was like summer camp and they
had the park to ourselves some nights
and lots of drama as we were all dating
each other and sick high school amazing
thank you so much guys that was
beautiful thank you I'm gonna allow to
eat this [ __ ] mm-hmm hi oh don't pee on
me
hello Oh puppies hey I'm Demi Lovato and
I'm hanging out with some puppies while
answering your questions how am I
supposed to start answering questions oh
you're so cute hello you're a boy I just
found that out I like the brown ones
they're playful
can you describe your new album tell me
you love me in three words nope
my album in three words would be
vulnerable raw and soulful here we go
nope would you release the song in
Spanish in the future if so which latin
artists would you like to collaborate
with I actually oh those are my pants oh
no honey you will have to wait and find
out because I recorded something
recently and that I think you will like
oh my god why did you decide to name
your album tell me you love me I decided
to name my album tell me you love me
because it's one of my favorite songs
off of the album and it also is a very
vulnerable and raw title oh no it on his
face you want bones boom no how is this
album different than confident or any of
your other albums this album is
different than my other albums because
it's more soulful and I think it's the
most mature out of all the albums that
I've made and I've done a lot of growing
up personally and professionally so I
think that that's the reason why you can
help me read the question I recently
just got out of a long-term relationship
I was wondering how you deal with a
breakup I deal with a breakup by leaning
on my closest friends and by getting out
into the dating scene again I think that
it's important not to dwell on uncertain
things and just to get back out there
and have fun oh my god this these are my
pants and that's my finger and that's my
next question
are you planning on directing are you
planning on directing more of your music
videos like how you directed
made-in-the-usa love to direct at some
point but maybe the next one who knows
you've had such an amazing career so far
what has been your best achievement I
think having a number one single was
definitely a career highlight and also
getting my grandma nomination what's
your favorite tattoo that you have and
are you planning on getting more I'm not
planning on getting more as of right now
but that'll change I'm sure my favorite
tattoo is my lion on the hand you're an
inspiration to your fans and to other
people who have gone through tough times
what does it mean to you to be able to
inspire and change the lives of others
through your fame I think that it's
really important that you use your
platform for good and if I've been able
to use my tough times and use them as
theirs puppies I don't know there's
puppies I think that if I'm able to use
the difficult times that I've been
through as lessons for other people then
I think I'm happy to inspire others nope
those are my questions
what song on your newest album do you
think is the most personal I think the
most personal song on this album is
either you don't do it for me anymore or
ready for you I think
ready for you is a song that I wrote
that explains a lot about a breakup that
I went through after watching your cover
of silent night I couldn't help but
think would you ever consider making a
Christmas album I have considered making
a Christmas album hopefully I'll do that
soon
you never know social media can be
really tough on a person mentally any
tips on staying sane and confident in a
world where every photo is face tuned
and photoshopped well I think that
learning to love yourself is very
important and learning to love yourself
in the skin that you're in is very
important it can be difficult at times
and of course the pressures are high but
I think that as long as you love
yourself that's all that matters what's
the most funniest the most funniest
memorable prank you've ever pulled and
who did you pull it on the funniest
pranks that I ever pulled on somebody
was I pulled a prank on my security
guard and in Vegas
it's legal to hire a lady of the night
to make surprise visits for somebody so
I did that and I sent her to my security
guards room and told her to be very
forceful and make herself enter the room
and she did just that and he was very
startled and I am glad that he didn't
keep her which song in this record was
the hardest to write slash record the
hardest song to record was smoke and
mirrors which is on the deluxe version
of the album it was a very emotional
song that I wrote on that basically
reminded me what are you doing vent
that's my elbow what are you doing that
reminded me of some very emotional times
that I went through do you want to act
again I think I would love to act at
some point I've just been so focused
with music right now that I haven't had
the chance to what has been your
favorite fan interaction or experience
I haven't had a favorite fan experience
because all of them are so special I
think that anytime a fan tells me that
I've saved their life is extremely
meaningful and it just matters so much
to me and it's kind of unfathomable so
it really means a lot last question
who's the first person you call when you
have good news the first person I call
is either my mom or my best friend
Marissa it's definitely my mom actually
and then I call Marissa but I tell them
good news and I get so excited for me
because they're so supportive and I love
them so much
interviewing with puppies was so much
fun they are so adorable I wish I could
take all of them home but you actually
can they are from North Shore Animal
League America and they're all up for
adoption so hashtag get your rescue on
so that's all I have I'm gonna go play
with puppies now because they're so
adorable
and they're very very playful right now
no don't do this to me my little puppy
okay so I'm Miley and I'm chillin with
BuzzFeed but more importantly not more
importantly but kind of I'm playing with
puppies this is the only way I do
interviews these days I tell my writer I
require puppies you love me baby pick
one okay we're gonna be answering some
fan questions you can summon up your eat
marine dream I mean great okay what does
being younger now mean to you well just
like these puppies all I want to do is
be with my family and be with my friends
and know it's important which is being
happy you want to pick all the sessions
with you okay I can't this is the worst
way to have me do an interview
I'm not leaving about this angel
next which hung from younger now is the
most special to you Malibu was the first
song that I wrote on this record so it's
extra special to me I my angel
what has been the most inspiring to you
during the creation of your new album I
broke my new album at my studio rainbow
land which is also a song that I sing
with Dolly Parton and so just being
around all the colors always really
inspired me okay what advice would you
give your 14 year old self never Google
yourself I read one time that if you
trust and love your decisions the less
that you care what other people think
about them so be happy with your
decisions are your songs for the younger
now put in a specific order to tell the
story or just put on the album in an
order for no specific reason everything
on the record has a reason in younger
now the song there's the sound of the
river that's at my house and in Malibu
that's where my house is and then
rainbow land is a studio at my house so
it's kind of like introducing people to
where I made the record and was inspired
by where I am and inspired by red
balloon
you guys are turn to the next how did it
feel to sing the song the climb for the
first time in ten years as good as it
feels holding my little angel your name
is angel and into angel that was my
grandmother's name when there was a
tragedy in Vegas there was so amazing to
be able to sing that song and be able to
make it current for whatever wanted to
be here that there's always gonna be
another mountain another struggle but
it's all about the climbs that's my
shirt okay you're getting my titties out
come on I have to keep the angel so do
you think what land will be so bad I
have any advice for young women who feel
repressed when it comes to their idea my
advice would be surround yourself with
friends who think like you but also make
sure you expose yourself to different
types of people but keep people around
you that always lifts you up and support
you you're my little friend you're my
best friend don't tell my other seven
dogs you know your name is turn because
you are turn if you could talk to your
animals and have them understand you
what would you want to tell them I would
hope that all of them know how much that
I love them
well I have no doubt in my mind that
they do because I treat them better than
my own family members
what's the sweetest thing a fan has ever
done for you I think my fans allowing me
to have happy hippy and the way that
they've really supported it and opened
up about themselves found my charity
angel demon if you weren't a singer what
would you be doing this 24 hours a day 7
days a week 365 your name is hectic your
name is church and your name is Alayne
Joe this was my favorite interview I've
ever done ever in the history of my life
for obvious puppy reasons
make sure you adopt these puppies
they're all available except maybe this
one from the North Shore Animal League
America look at you come on send to Liam
son Billy how do I answer this when
there's puppies running
[Music]
what are you talking about Santa comes
every year even the dogs are at odds
about this okay I can tell them they
just do what they want everything about
the holidays is just so much fun that I
don't even know how to explain it while
I'm watching these puppies fight with
each other they're so adorable I can't
believe they're here I'll be happy with
anything it's a thought the county
[Music]
they're too young betrayed so this is a
natural
[Applause]
all I left for Christmas is my the first
Christmas song that I ever wrote for my
first Christmas album which is called
Merry Christmas and there's a new
animated movie about a little girl that
wants a puppy for Christmas it's I'm
just here with posing and playing with
puppies talking about other things but
to answer your question but wait
[Music]
as soon as I get back in the studio
after Christmas because right now we're
celebrating the fact that we have
[Music]
I wasn't thinking about that I was
recording a Christmas song hi cookie
that's a boring answer what is this food
look at this please tell me you're
getting this adorable
BuzzFeed I have removed my shirt cuz the
bunny made me warm come back people
people people please come here real or
ask off little rascal my favorite part
about filming the Mazur movies was the
family oh my god he's shaking the family
that was made on set we all really had
an amazing time making these movies and
they're constantly fun and they're
constantly a joy to do which is super
rare
did he like sit up if I had to pick a
character I'd say truck cuz he was he
was like a second time he's like a dog
he's man's best friend
just like these dogs are my best friends
come here anytime on set with Tyler was
always the best Teen Wolf is like a
second home to me and Tyler's like a
brother the puppies I'm kidding there
are no puppies in the movie this film
this last movie answers all the
questions that fans and people who've
seen the first two may have so well it's
finally all gonna be wrapped up and
you're finally gonna be not confused
anymore if I were to give my younger
self one piece of advice it would be to
not be so shy lean into nerves or even
if it especially if it's involved
something that you know you genuinely
enjoy don't let fear and kind of nerves
or shyness keep you away from you from
doing that because it almost kept me
away from acne but not the puppy cocker
spaniel cuz that was my dog growing up I
gotta take this off I'm getting hot
[Music]
Tyler Posey again or anyone on my team
of cast mates or any one of my Maze
Runner cast mates one of the biggest
part of those things ending is realized
and you you know you don't know when
you're gonna work with these guys again
so and it would I would jump at the
chance to always stay grounded and just
be you always a normal and just to value
your roots and your friends it's easy to
get caught up in the industry or in
Hollywood or whatever if you're young
actor but no it's important oh my god
can we zoom in on that there was some
Butthead nuzzling going on nose went
back into his breath
[Music]
none of them I made a music video one
time it hahaha are we getting this Oh No
was that too much for you first video I
ever posted to my channel was this
little music video that me and my best
friends from New Jersey made and that
was like how I started my channel
because then my friend was like oh you
should put this on YouTube and I was
like what's YouTube and then I just made
an account put that video up there and
then that became my youtube channel no I
think they probably had a few weeks and
broke up or something
she's complicated that one is yeah yeah
they're destined to be together
they love that sandbag you know not as
often as we like I think it's it's tough
when you're trying to see people you
know in the industry so it's tough
everyone's always away or traveling it's
rare to be in the same place at one time
but given all that I'd say I've see them
pretty often I see Tyler all the time
[Music]
all the major movies always taught me
something as an actor and a person go
ahead venture out
yes no what was the question you was
trying to get your legs and shape a
little bit cuz you're running major huh
next question
[Music]
I don't know if you can call what I did
on new girl singing and yeah I would
love to be in a musical I don't think
I'd ever be allowed to be in one if I
can't sing I was what oh if I wasn't
sure if I wasn't it active
guys come on the grand finale
all three poppy side work with little
puppies
[Music]
[Applause]
even I don't beyond me are they don't
beyond me don't do it
no okay I'm excited for them to see what
condoms African people who are
self-determining women living in their
power what a time for black times it to
come out it's why it's bringing people
together people gonna go see it together
hopefully dress up when they do it this
is a part of Black History there now
where you gonna go
Oh God okay this movie is full of
incredibly talented actors and we have
legends like Forrest Whitaker
Angela Bassett and then we have
newcomers like the Tichenor right and
Daniel Kahlua and they're badasses we
have big meals together we went to this
African restaurant more than once and
you just took it took it over
we enjoyed spending time together on and
off set we had like a six-week boot camp
and we'd have a group session with all
the doormen lodging and then we'd break
off and learn our individual skills it
was really tough on the body but also
really cool because the more I exerted
physically the more I felt like I was
getting into the Nakia zone of it all I
lost one puppy I believe the only one
that likes me my skincare routine well
I'm a low maintenance kind of person
stay hydrated and then I use a light
moisturizer Lancome de creme that's
known as energy Davi I try and not wear
makeup when I don't need it and then I'm
very religious about taking my makeup
off avocado oil to take off my makeup
because it's gentle okay what do I have
here enough to say
at some point you're back now you're
back okay who's gonna win and then now
you want to get in the mix all right
come on come on we've got it he's got it
I love you you're so sweet
this is horrible to do to a person who
loves animals I do not need more animals
oh my god but they're so adorable if you
all get these puppies and you separate
these sisters I will haunt you when I'm
dead
hey what's up yo I'm Kelly Clarkson and
I am hanging out with puppies so I'll
answering y'all's questions so it's
basically the best afternoon ever okay
here we go let's start you want it you
want this one if something went down and
you had one phone call to get someone to
help you out who do you call Blake
Shelton's Adam Levine or Alicia Keys oh
it depends on this scenario I mean I
think I'd call Blake we've I know him a
little better than the others but I
don't know I feel like Adam could charm
my way out of a situation and Alicia
Keys has this weird gravitational pull
to like humans so she could help me out
too I don't know people fall for the
southern charm I'd probably call Blake
have you heard from any of the people
who influenced meaning of life Toni
Braxton Bonnie Raitt Michelle Obama
right sorry it's so weird that you say
this because I did get a handwritten
letter from Michelle Obama about go high
which I obviously wrote inspired by the
message you know she gave at the
Democratic convention and that's why I
said it to her
um they like to tickle your toes okay
let's um he likes my rainbow nails um
you've got to stop tickling my toe
it's an emergency and you need a
babysitter Simon Cowell koala dual or
Justin Guarini I like a person that can
discipline so I'm probably gonna pick
Simon and he has a kid oh now so he
knows how to lay down the law watch him
actually be a softie with kids though
hey you want to play what did you do do
do-do-do do-do-do to be named a Disney
character you'd love to sing a duet with
that's hard
I actually really dig Pocahontas the
voice of Pocahontas I think her voice is
amazing
she was just rad you know what I feel
like a lot of the princesses are like
damsels and she was like I got this John
Smith follow me like I loved her my
daughter loves pecans to tickle you like
pantyhose my man what is one thing you
learned from the artist on your team on
the voice um I get I think you're the
attack I guess I'd say I don't really
get nervous so it's been kind of a thing
to help people with nervous energy I
don't actually know that I'm helpful cuz
I'm like just get over it you might suck
you might regret he thought you know but
probably just how to really be a coach
and you know instead of me just doing I
have to kind of help like mold and teach
they're everywhere out of it I mean does
he love me or what like he has not left
me I love you here let me answer another
one wouldn't you and it helped me what's
the first thing you do when you find
yourself home alone
oh I cry of happiness no no no um you I
I don't know I guess I grab a glass of
wine y'all that's not that's few and far
between we hope for kids though and oh
oh my gosh okay so in 2012 you said you
had a killer song that you wanted paint
Gaga Jesse J to sing with you what
happened about well no one answered so
no one answered my call I didn't
actually call him I just sent it on
Twitter cuz I'm gonna be awkward if they
didn't want to do it so um but I did it
was the song that was actually ended up
on my album piece by piece and it was
called dance with me come on and dance
with me it's like this like Bowie kind
of Abba vibe and I loved it and like
literally you are so beautiful and you
will not leave me
and I love him what song would you
really like to cover as a fan request on
your next tour anything from the Harry
Styles album I love it or evolve imagine
dragons that's good I love I love both
those albums right now they're pretty
rad or kardi because I just think it'd
be fun to watch me sing like red Potter
whose ship is budgets would be bad red
bottom heels no wait that's it wrong
feet already I'm not it's not a fit I've
grown up listening to so many of your
songs which one is your favorite to
perform whoo my favorite old school song
like from the beginning is Miss
independent still live it's so much
better than on record my favorite new
song ever to perform like above all it's
a whole lot of woman off this new album
eating of life it is it gives me life on
so many levels
oh my god on my bike and this is the
worst situation for me I'm gonna buy all
these dogs or take them fall what is
this silliest gift you have ever
received it was at a show and a girl
threw me her Brawl and it was supposed
to be funny like we support you get it
but I was like this is not an Aerosmith
concert Kelly Clarkson concert like but
it was funny so points for being clever
I would have a beer with you I would
have some wine with you I don't really
enjoy beer too much if you can seem up
with four other badass women is to form
a girl band who would you pick oh I'd
probably pick I said earlier that I
wanted to sing I'd I pick pink and Jesse
J I mean I love so many Adele Alicia
Keys like decide to pick a bunch of just
like soulful singer there's a lot of
women I love Demi I love Jimmy what was
it like to finally meet Steve Carell in
person how did you feel about that Kelly
Clarkson it was awesome you know I was
awesome because he was actually really
cool sometimes you meet people and that
doesn't happen exactly they know what
I'm talking about
exactly that's what you want to do to
him okay one more did you ever vote for
anyone else while you were on American
Idol
did you ever vote for yourself I never
never voted on my season not even for
myself which is dumb like I should have
I really don't need a dog like another
dog but somebody does you need love you
need this love and like why would you
not want this look at this this is
loyalty is you're just like it's story
time
oh here I I'm getting sucked into the
vortex my husband will kill me you also
be wanted even come on they're so cute
got Leo Selma Louise got copper and look
at they want a home they need a home and
you can do it
puppies are so much cooler than humans
like come on all right so if you want
one of y'all gotta look up North Shore
Animal League America
you gotta find them you got it you gotta
make a little friend for life and don't
separate the sisters please come on get
film elites together they could be
buddies I want to know vanilla bean baby
it's like they love you yeah
[Music]
I'm so distracted I could look at this
little guy stuff like this you know this
is what I set out to do was just play
with puppies all the time I think the
great thing about acting is that you can
step into somebody else's shoes without
suffering the consequences I was a kind
of person who was like I was a swimmer I
also really loved art and I train like
classically as a vocalist for 10 years
right watch the Gaga concert and I
started writing music and then I at the
end of that year I was in phenomenal and
I didn't get in and so I decided to do
it a plumber's music theater and then
from that I figured I liked the acting
thing anyway so now I'm here what's your
drag name it's hard I would I'd get on
board with that drag name what breed of
dog are you I have a what's your
temporary good I don't know if I'm
swearing lesbian sir oh yeah yeah what
did you know that's I hope that this
movie furthers a conversation of
representation and inclusiveness and
tolerance see your story represented on
a screen is a really powerful thing
I think representation is is crucial
it's so important to see people who look
like you and act like you and to see
stories that you can relate to because
it's what it's what makes you feel not
crazy or not alone and this is a story
that's kind of it's overdue but I hope
that it normalizes those feelings
because I think it's so underrepresented
in the media and you know if you don't
see those stories you don't understand
them and then it makes it weird to be
that and I just I think it takes so much
courage to come out and hopefully this
film can know much you get talking point
to ease it all sex just like a scene in
the movie if you watch it there's
something exactly this happens except
the dog is maybe not quite as cute
I might have to come with me
[Music]
I feel like now more than ever is a time
where you can find a community or
whether it's online or can find people
with like-minded views don't be afraid
to be vulnerable
I can't give personal advice because
like everyone's story is different and
I've never had to go through coming out
or anything like that knowing that like
you're not alone and your friends if
they're real friends will accept you and
love you and know there's guys are no
friends we have to separate you - I
[Music]
never fit in like I was an athlete but I
was also musical when I was also a super
nerd but also like none of them ever
felt right you're conflicting ideas of
like you're trying so hard to be
authentically you but at the same time
you're like Who am I and trying to like
figure that out what would you like in
high school Nick I feel like I was kind
of a misfit I didn't really belong to
any one group I've never had do anything
with puppies before this is harder than
I thought it was going to be him
don't try and fit in as hard don't be
afraid to be vulnerable and trust your
instincts
a little bit more high schools a time
when you know you're trying really hard
to express yourself but you don't always
have the tools emotional tools to do
that just pet puppies my advice would be
keep doing what you're doing cuz I feel
like I wouldn't change anything I read
it did you read it mhm yeah yeah I would
Oscar I love to such a fangirl of a book
I reached out to Becky on Instagram and
just like BAM here this is your guy
adapting a novel for a film is tricky
because the backstory you have to
include in like an hour and a half baby
don't leave me you want a little
backstory the novel's really great in
the book they go much more into like
Leah and her insecurities and I think
that's a really large part of what's
going on with her is like not only the
whole emotional journey but also how she
feels about herself I got to read the
book and it just added a lot of depths
these characters like maybe this is
because of her background she used to be
a school counselor but she's really good
at making these characters
three-dimensional and showing their
their journey
I think we did justice to it I hope that
that if you liked the book you're like
the movie and if you've never read the
book I highly recommend checking it out
went to Savannah which was cool except
for the ghosts here did not enjoy that
oh yeah Savannah was actually the best
part of that yeah you also taught me how
to drive I knew how to drive you drove
on the other side of the road yeah
you've driven a car before yeah no no no
I joined a car you didn't eat let's
specify you didn't teach me how to drive
but oh babe come on it's not fun
what's my finger it's not like
delectable or something what sorry
puppies
[Music]
definitely not ready to direct a movie
but if I was to direct a film I like
movies that are hard to pin down
I like Donnie Darko like something along
those lines your mind maybe I mean Jake
Gyllenhaal and Donnie when I watched it
I was like that's Nick yeah yeah
actually don't know if that's a
compliment
thank you Tom okay I don't feel ready to
direct something I'd like to direct but
I like if I did it I would want to be
ready to do it I really like the idea of
capturing parts of yourself that you
keep to yourself and you don't show to
people I think that's really cool
actually I had this idea to tell like
when you fall in love with someone but
from like a girl's perspective for
another girl like I had a friend who
told me about that and she just had a
really beautiful story oh god I can't
even think I can barely like think about
what I'm doing tomorrow I can't believe
five to ten years yeah likes a dreamer
acting gonna sit quietly yeah I'll tell
you I'd also like to do some music
because I think I came from a music
background I like the last two years to
me if and I did like there's reasons and
I did this and they're just coming out
now but like I think music is still at
my core so I don't know maybe put some
music out because my friends desperately
want me to do that because I've known me
since I started writing so we'll see
closely I was thank you so much she's
not leaving me
[Music]
what is your idea of a perfect day today
Playa papi no one wants to play with me
come here hi hi I'm Megan Trainor and I
get to answer some questions with rescue
puppies best day ever
unlike the Aussie you're all so cute
okay polo they're fighting oh that's so
cute
okay I'm gonna answer these questions
there we go what's the biggest thing
you've splurged on since you became
famous I bought a Tesla they don't know
how they're gonna eat the papers I just
did ever myself yes I did oh they have
plans looking I'm sorry did you grow up
watching your fiance and spy kids like
the rest of us did of course I did the
first time I ever met him was at a party
two years before our first date a
songwriting party I was at and I went up
to him I went right up to him and I've
never had done that to like a celebrity
before and was like excuse me are you
Spy Kids and he was like yeah and I
would yell check this out guys Spy Kids
and he'll yell Megan and I was like you
remembered my name
so I had my whole fangirl moment and
sometimes I told him when we were dating
in the early days that sometimes when he
laughed I would see juni they were young
juni Cortez and I had to get over that
and now I see a man and a very handsome
man that I love very much
okay we're using video of yours is your
all-time favorite are there any that you
would change now if you could oh great
question I would say my favorite there's
no excuses right now because we worked
really hard on that one and there's a
lot of Me's and I got to be triplets
right and which one I would change I
don't know I probably wouldn't change
any up base right yeah even though that
was a big video I
like I didn't have a make up squad at
the time and I was very new to
everything and I didn't say a lot of
what I wanted and I would have changed
I think someone looks up but there are
so famous and iconic that it worked out
well okay what is the most ridiculous
rumor you've heard about yourself that I
died got a lot of those got a lot of I'm
pregnant and I'm dead so I'm good I'm
healthy I'm alive
I sent the the passing of our sweet
beloved mega trainer send that article
to my mom and she was like this is not
even funny do not send me this so don't
say that if I'm alive oh yeah oh that's
some sweet lovin oh hi
okay okay weird my question where worked
at what was your inspiration behind your
new single no excuses I wanted to write
a big anthem for my way back and I
wanted to mean something and I've had
personal experiences with respect and
people respecting each other of all ages
so I wanted to write a fun happy song
that was like a modern-day version of
resp ECT respect me you know there's no
excuse treat others the way you want to
be treated like puppies
you are so pretty you are so pretty what
is this face you're a special mix look
at you okay what is your favorite memory
while writing this album my favorite
memory while writing this album is
having my family singing on backgrounds
and trying to record them and not make a
mess and well you are dead it's really
hard to focus on the questions when you
got puppies in your face oh yeah you
want a question okay sweet thing but you
get one too okay okay here's one can you
give us a hint as to what the rest of
the album will be like an inspiration
behind some other songs
okay the rest the album's gonna be
pop anthems a lot about love about
happiness and songs about loving
yourself every song is like a dance song
except one there's a beautiful ballad in
there and the inspiration was my life
and experience as I go through all right
what are you doing we're we're come here
hey hey no fighting sir okay who has
been the most inspiring to you during
your creation of your new album I listen
to a lot of Ablow before this and og pop
like Britain young Britney Spears would
like a she is so lucky bump thump thump
listen to that a lot love how the
backgrounds are in there and love the
vocalists all over these songs Max
Martin back in the dude that was my jam
and so I grew up on NSYNC and Backstreet
Boys I listened to a lot of that when I
was writing so you'll hear big pop songs
like that yes you will
yes you will come on in okay is it cuz
you want this that's why you want me
okay here we go all right if you could
change one thing you've done in the past
what would it be
Yemeni if I could change one thing in
the past I wouldn't because I'm here now
and that's all that matters haha did you
want this question you can't eat it
let me read it first what's your
favorite song to perform live no excuses
cuz it's easier than every other song
ever written
oh and it's actually a fun time which
girls guys come here I got the bag oh
look it's in my hand
okay okay which celebrity left you
starstruck when you met them Adele yes I
do you got it in the bag don't give you
the bags hey yeah hey go I'm gonna calm
down
okay chill chill out yeah okay your
fiance Darryl's the bad things on your
new album what was it like to work
together professionally oh it was always
fun it didn't feel like professional
work he was really good he's a good
singer something's happening here that
is rated R right now are you will are
you a freak you will freak Oh
babies yes come on in which celeb what
you die to have signature wedding
Oh Lud can they be dead or alive I would
die to have Frank Sinatra even though
can't do that one
push it singing our wedding that won't
Oh Bruno Bruno come sing for me singing
my weddings going to your concert you
know like the same okay what is your
favorite lyric of all of your songs is
we're not promised tomorrow like imma
lose you that song
I'm lyric if you could go back and give
your teen self advice what would you say
I would say don't with stress so much
stop having so much stress like relax
you're a kid you're not an adult yet
adult life is much different but also
time will heal all and you look better
when you get older so don't freak out
you know I think we did it kids if you
wanna dump these amazing sweet puppies
go to North Shore Animal League America
my god hello angels okay Avenger we're
gonna call you Noah yeah well what is
this one peewee I like it he seems like
a you he's a goofy
[Music]
hi I'm Brendon Urie from panic at the
disco and I'm gonna be answering your
fan submitted questions while hanging
out with puppies let's see how well I
can see okay here we go first one hard
you beautiful okay okay the identity
okay you want to eat this okay since
you've taken to Broadway acting is there
any chance we could see you in other
acting gigs perhaps on TV what if it
involves dogs absolutely I will do a dog
film a Marley & Me but opposite where I
save all the docks
that's what happens well you should
sweet okay pushing through pushing
through what's your favorite tattoo and
why oh it's definitely bite and a bite
um it's definitely my one that I got off
my wife's eye inside of her favorite
flower which is the yellow rose I love
that one oh it's very tiny
have you seen love Simon and if so what
did you think about Panik being featured
in I haven't seen it yet I'm going to
very soon I was very flattered a fan had
tweeted me a synopsis of all the
mentions of panic
I remember getting the email like a year
and a half ago we had talked about it
and we signed up it was under a
different name I can't remember but I
was like yeah this sounds like a really
cool story and then sure enough it ends
up in the movie and like that's the
coolest thing that's like you know the
biggest compliment we see especially
have a movie like that it's just so
forward-thinking I love it I don't like
good news okay - question like what this
party for a little bit
if you can have one panic at the disco
lyric tattooed what would it be and
where would you put it oh jeez
that's a tough one I would just put
close the goddamn door and just right
across my ass okay great okay do fans
ever quote your finds to you when you
meet them and which one is your personal
favorite yeah the first time I got
recognized for not being in panic I went
to a movie I stepped out and these two
really sweet girls came up and said hey
are you that guy from fine and it took
me a second is the first time I was
asked I was like oh yeah yeah yeah yes I
am and I started singing this coffee one
that I had done so that was very cool
thank you
name is Jesse thank you let's see how
thank you you're just lounging like a
little boss hi would you ever consider
doing another Broadway show and what
would your dream role be absolutely I
was raised in the Mormon faith so I
would love to be an elder price that
would be great
the only problem is I have a full sleeve
of tattoos and most missionaries are in
short sleeves so we'll see make up make
up what made you decide to call your
fans sinners
again I I grew up in the Mormon Church
and it was just kind of a little
juxtapose to what I was taught was
always taught that I was a sinner I'm no
good not good enough for heaven so I
just think it's ironic how did you know
that Sarah was the one first time I met
her she was not single and there was
definitely a chemistry there but I knew
[ __ ] that she was down and very cool
because I made her a lunchable with a
Capri Sun and she was totally down it
was like fancy to her is like over
nerves it's like a canapes it was great
if you could create or contribute to the
soundtrack of any movie which one would
it be
oh my goodness I think I've said it
before I would love to do like the
overdub and the Foley for a Jason
Statham movie you know where I do like
all the punches me like do his you know
yelling and stuff well if you could
choose one or two bands to go on tour
with you who would they be and why one
or two bands let's do them I'm just a
massive Kendrick fan Kendrick Lamar that
would be dub just let me open I'll do
five minutes a stand-up I'll sell your
merch whatever bro let me let me hang
what is the last thing you do before
going on stage and the first thing you
do coming off stage last thing I do for
going on stage I watch the band hit the
stage and walk out it's usually just a
rush of emotions but right before that
we do our pre-show shot to kill the
hyper-awareness
now we have done a whiskey shot and it
just all made us grumpy so we know brown
liquor before the show so we do one shot
of tequila and then right after we come
off we like that my favorite way to come
off the stages and Elvis exit which
means you just go from stage right into
a van right to the hotel into a shower
and pass out that's the best show for me
I don't have to
was there an audition process for kinky
boots and if so what was it like not
really which I was nervous for I was
flattered that they would give me the
part but I was very nervous for it
basically I had DB bonds who flew out to
LA he's the Associate Director for kinky
boots he flow out for two days we did an
hour each day of just reading through
the script talking about motivations
that was pretty much it and we had about
a week of rehearsal teaching me the
dance moves putting my heels on and then
it was Showtime and my put in rehearsal
I dropped a glass on the stage and it
shattered and my heart shattered
hopefully that was the worst of it no I
would continue to [ __ ] up every night
but it was fun it was fun what's the
most memorable weird thoughtful etc gift
you have received from a fan weird or
thoughtful
I got a voodoo doll which usually you
would keep the voodoo doll but I they
gave it to me of myself so you know if
ever I feel like what
called flagellating in a way I'll just
poke the dog come correct what is the
new album's overall genre hmm is it
gonna be all jazz like as what you've
mentioned in one of your live sessions
before no every song is different I love
doing that yeah they're all kind of all
over the place you know there's one that
feels like you're in a club but it
sounds like you're at a hot topic if hot
topic we're a club I guess yeah
would you ever consider writing another
song with f OB absolutely I love those
guys I love I love Fall Out Boy they're
my homies they've always been really
inclusive like including me and all
their stuff and they're just big
brothers always get the paper I picked
what was some titles for this new album
that you thought about but didn't end up
going with I was gonna call it a like a
Lord Byron quote which I thought was
really nice it wasn't love love not man
less but nature more it was famous of
thirsty youth which I thought was a
really cool quote but yeah it's prey for
the wicked I just thought that tied in
everything actually that I was talking
about what was your first impression of
Pete Wentz did you think you guys would
have the relationship that you have now
no not at all
Pete was very cool he was in LA making
his record with Fall Out Boy and I
remember walking up and being like wow
this guy looks like a rock star and then
we went back to the practice space and
played some stuff allows the puppy part
solid Alpo gasps yeah I didn't I didn't
think that we would you know I didn't
know what was gonna come of meeting Pete
and getting signed in all this stuff so
yeah it's just it's gotten better over
time
my big brother I am dying to know how
the performances differed between a
panic at the disco concert and appearing
as Charlie pricing kinky boots on
Broadway very different I'll say the
biggest difference is that with a panic
show
luckily the fans you guys are louder
than me sometimes and you save me in
moments where I might forget a lyric or
a voice crack happens but in kinky boots
you're up there and spotlights on you
and you if you mess up everybody hears
it you're under a microscope and that
was very exciting coming from a person
who deals with anxiety and wants to
become a performer one day how do you
cope with anxiety on stage or even
during the whole touring process very
good question I used to take medication
then I stopped taking it just came to a
realization that I
didn't want to go there so then I
adopted the art of breathing breathing
exercises that really ended up helping
me a lot more than I thought it would
which is pretty great so thanks for that
question
I know performing can be very anxiety
driven so I believe in what is your plan
for the future of panic at the disco
after this album I don't know I've
talked about like doing weird stuff like
after the Broadway thing building a show
like that taking it on the road
not necessarily with an album but just
kind of building the idea of a show it
wouldn't just be an album I don't I
don't know there's something there
exactly something in their favorite Fall
Out Boy song or lyric right now I like
Church that one's great great did you
guys have her actually consider
yourselves emo when you started as a
band no we never did but we listened to
a lot of bands that were considered emo
so yeah we were never offended by it
it's like if you wanted to call this emo
yeah well good
which person that you've met or which
interaction that you've had do you think
it's had the biggest influence on how
you want to be seen just generally the
person wow that's a deep question I'm a
believer in the butterfly effect right
like so if I you know everybody I come
in contact with has an influence on
something that will happen in the future
for me I got to meet President Obama in
the first lady that was Michelle and
Barack man that that was crazy waiting
in line I was so anxious and stepped in
me and my wife and watching her meet
them first I was just this is actually
happening this is really crazy very tall
very beautiful people shift my hand and
I just kind of shuddered a little bit I
said you are you were just great and I'm
a big admirer of yours and just thank
you and he said that's a very snappy
suit I thought was great okay last one
would you ever be a judge on RuPaul's
Drag Race I feel like it would be a
perfect fit for you
abso lutely that would be a blast are
you kidding I would love to be a
contestant on there too yeah we'll
figure something out I just would love
to be in drag yeah vengers my dude
yeah dude oh you're the sweetest yeah
you're protecting me hey I just want to
thank BuzzFeed man for setting this out
because what this is the dopest better
hey by the way you guys want to adopt
North Shore Animal League America did
you take off fourth it's four times the
happiness broken today we are going to
do an interviews gonna feed your puppies
oh yeah there's the one come in red
little red okay the answer fans
questions let's see are you gonna read
it you gonna read a read you're stranded
on a desert island oh you're good your
hair dressing up you're stranded on a
desert island which of these people
you've worked with before do you want
with you Tyler Perry Octavia Spencer
Terrence Howard or Brad Pitt I'm gonna
go with Tyler Perry because he adds its
own private jet which one which one you
pick about you think guilt like that Oh
Becca what character have you enjoyed
playing than mostly well your career and
why I think I would have to say Vernell
Watson from talked to me because she was
flyy she was in 70s up we have our next
question the movie was set in the 70s
and I loved her wardrobe but she was she
was the real cookie what's your biggest
deal breaker when it comes to
relationships chewing on the ears flying
you can't lie to me
if you do I'll turn into Melinda
oh this was too long whoever that is I'm
not answering that
that's the paragraph
sorry a little kitty what is the
craziest or scariest thing that happens
to you on set while filming acrimony
these puppies right now yeah I got my
way honey
I guess the scariest thing I had to do
was to jump in this pool in the middle
wee hours of the night or morning and oh
[Music]
that was another movie next question can
you share one funny or embarrassing fact
that most people don't really know about
you
I'm coming gassy do you want to come on
with me now you try to come over date
will be gonna call you let us spend some
time with you fourth thing misty misty
misty we have read OK at Francie and
misty did I do good I think I did good
can you figure out who's read right can
you figure out those misty misty know
what we doing we're doing interviews ok
so it says acrimony has a lot to do with
being able to truly live in front of
your dog truly being able to let things
go what advice do you have for someone
to be able to really just move forward
and move on see that's your that's a
great question for you I would tell
people that if you spend so much time in
your life looking back you can't get to
what's in front of you you can't get to
what's ahead of you because you miss the
great things that are wasted by look
papi they moving on just move on just
move on what are some of the weirdest
jobs you had before becoming an actress
I was a singing dancing waitress I
wouldn't call that very weird because I
was
which celebrity makes you laugh the most
all of these puppies are available for
adoption at North Shore Animal League of
America adopt adopt don't shop and their
faces are beautiful yeah yeah Raja's
take it all for home you know how much I
travel I don't have a private jet you
gonna help me with that mr. Barry get
this my advice okay if you just really
believe in yourself I know you're doing
your best and you're proud of the way
you're living then one day you might
wind up on a pink backdrop just like
playing with a [ __ ] ton of puppies
what's better motivation than that hi
I'm Amy Schumer and I'm answering fan
questions while playing with puppies
okay guys are you ready have you ever
had an embarrassing workout story an
incident happened to you like Renee and
I feel pretty well this dog just like
kind of peed on me an embarrassing
workout experience yeah I've had a lot
oh one time when I was working out and
going for a walk in Austin I got I [ __ ]
myself you guys know what that's like oh
you even wanna he just wants love okay
sorry questions okay Renea is a
traumatic online group date experience
have you had a bad online dating
experience I was online dating for like
truly 24 hours and it was dramatic
enough that I wanted to get out of there
but then I've also had you know I also
met a guy I had like a nice couple years
relationship with from online so I've
got no online hate but you kind of start
to feel really bad about yourself you
know it's like you kind of get judged
like this is how much you're worth yeah
and it makes you feel bad about yourself
it's such a meat market but I don't know
a lot of people fell in love on there
like we just fell in love but I think
we've got these dogs online
I like that there's wet footprints and
like we know it it's from I'm stranded
on a desert island which of these people
that I've worked with before do I want
with me Goldie Hawn LeBron James
Jennifer Lawrence or John Cena Goldie
Hawn hands down Goldie is you want to be
stuck anywhere with her because Jennifer
would eat me you know she'd be like this
is fun we'll have fun and then she'd
start looking at me like I was a chicken
really fast but Goldie would you know
we'd at least party for a little while
first okay what makes you feel pretty
puppies I feel pretty oh that's actually
thank you thank you sir yeah beer on
your friends that I know it sounds corny
but seriously when you're just like with
your friends and you're laughing and you
just feel really like yourself and
authentic and yeah but also when someone
has sex with you you feel pretty you're
like okay I must have looked well enough
that I you wanted have sex with me so
that's a compliment
how will married life change your
stand-up material sir um I don't know I
just started doing it I mean it's
nobody's ever gonna text me you up again
so I'll just have to start just you know
talking about ma'am ma'am ma'am ma'am
she Vaughn she ma'am oh I can't stay mad
at you
uh I don't know I just need to get a lot
of dogs you're a little biter okay
Jennifer Lawrence recently said you gave
her some tough love after a breakup she
ever given you similar advice well I
didn't give her advice I just sent her
flowers saying that I was sorry that she
was gonna die alone and I stand by that
I love Jennifer she's one of my best
friends and you know she's beautiful on
camera and she's she's an incredible
actress but in a person when you're with
Jennifer's up close she it all melts
away and she's very hideous Jenn is um
yeah I knew I could mess with Jenn about
her breakup she'll she'll bounce back
quick what what if that was an important
question what if this happened with the
the Constitution what's the craziest
rumor you've ever heard about yourself
um I read a rumor once that I had I
don't even want to say this but it was
that I'd gone to jail for punching
someone in the face at the Oscars and
I've never gone to the Oscars but yeah
it was written this fact Congrats on
your marriage how and when did you know
your husband was the one when he
introduced himself as a chef you worked
with Michelle Williams and busy and I
feel free where you big Dawson's Creek
fan growing up yes of course I have a
beating heart so of course I like
Dawson's Creek
what are you doing cuz you just got very
still all of a sudden and I'm definitely
concerned about that what about you look
at this little face are you so
[Music]
what celebrity makes you laugh the most
[Music]
what celebrity makes me laugh the most
the the funniest you know your teeth are
no joke like we got to be real Dave
Attell makes me laughing was the
comedian and he's in the movie truly
biting glass truly you hear a little
vampire you're like Robert Pattinson
look at this I'm gonna name you Robert
Pattinson and you're Kristen Stewart and
you're Anna Kendrick and you're Taylor
something
Momsen all these puppies are available
for adoption at North Shore Animal
League America except for this one you
want oh look oh why is this what is this
[Music]
hi I'm Neil Patrick Harris and I've been
asked to read questions while playing
with copies and how do you say no to
that
Oh what is one of your weirdest or
funniest fan encounters I had an old
tiny fan once with the lead is squeaky
so then I got one of the newer Dyson
fans that's better if you had to get
count a lot one genuine compliment what
would it be
he is devilishly handsome he has a metal
that means not metal like your collar
let me metal thumpeka what are your
plans after the third season I'm
assuming last season because it will
cover the last thoughts of a fortunate
event and when it wraps filming will you
go back to Broadway
ok that's mom that's my life I love my
shirt thank you I'd love to go back to
Broadway someday I'm looking forward to
resting certain important events is
super fun but all kinds of exhausting
much like you know when you really have
to take a dump but you're you can't
because you're not outside you know that
feeling yeah and you really gotta go and
then finally going aha I need a rest
that's kind of my life right now hey
question what's the craziest rumor
you've ever heard about yourself
and I was on Malcolm in the Middle in a
movie about your life who would you want
to play you and David Oh answer the
question who would play me Josh Duhamel
and who would play David Nick Jonas next
question this is my favorite allowed to
pick her favorite what in your opinion
was cuddle off best in the skies they're
all pretty good I think I like detective
Duval the best right he's in the vial
Village episodes I neither hipster man
he talks like this everything that he
says is cool would have oh cool is there
a celebrity that you met that left you
completely starstruck
David Franco
easy to look at to put it bluntly Count
Olaf is a garbage human how do you get
into character to play such a despicable
person it's kind of easy because if
you're ever grumpy or wishing that you
were a jerk I get down and negative you
can just channel to channel that into
the character how often do you get to
play someone that is downright awful
answer me you still talk to the Kim
Myint ask would you ever consider
collaborating or reuniting with path
down the line I do still talk with
getting down mostly cobie smulders
because we have kids there's similar
ages and she I'm terren her husband
lived in New York for a bit like yeah we
text and shoot the breeze I don't think
we'd have a reunite on this ship you all
right now you are a troublemaker yes you
are yes thank you these are so cute
these dogs you played a lot of really
different characters do you have a
favorite one my favorite would probably
I don't know surely say no it was fun
she was a girl when I sort of got the
better like she was in Mad Men she
talked like this it was less fun when I
had to pee because I was wearing padding
and Spanx
and it's kind of talking you know do you
appreciate when fans come up to you in
public or is it annoying no it's never
annoying I like fans when they come up I
like when people say nice thing less fun
is when they just try and take your
picture while you're eating at a
restaurant that's never a good picture I
might talk until the conversation to
scowling something I look over something
nice that's always fun to hear right
[Music]
would you ever hook the Tonys again oh I
would love to do that again a hard job
though maybe some here need to think of
time off the Tonys Great Falls
great show to host if there's all the
performances it's the best weren't show
to watch and it's all performances by
people who are doing shows live so then
you get the live show
all around what did you learn as a young
actor in India House remedy that help
you later in life as an adult actor how
to suture my own boys out of the
neutered dogs that hasn't told me that
much less than the most memorable moment
of your life that you would like to
cherish forever oh then the birth of my
children holding newborn babies anything
new that's a pretty amazing thing kids
by the way wouldn't love these nice I
would be leaving with four more dogs how
can you go about choosing the themes for
your family how to link off with each
year and can you hint to some potential
options to this year no hints
we have talked about it it's much more
of a negotiation now because the kids
speak the English language and have
opinions before let's go my idea here
put on this lion costume here you look
like Dorothy snap now it's come on it'll
be fun
you're gonna do this you're gonna wear
this order don't know what do you think
happened with Barney after the show
ended and what did he be up to now
[Music]
probably the same old same old what
would he be up to two fingers of scotch
and probably 15 check once your go-to
karaoke song that's a good question
Rocketman good I tend to go with Elton
John songs cuz they're fun I also know
all the words that the devil went down
to georgia Julia that was my my New
Mexico rap days he was in a pond he was
way behind if you want to make a deal
when they came across this young man's
song we build in a plan what's your idea
of a perfect day playing with puppies
well probably the perfect day would be
with my family in Hawaii on the beach
thinking a pina colada and writing
Disney theme park attractions
I don't think those it didn't be
impractical in Hawaii but that would be
a perfect day okay that's my arm thank
you
out of all the villains that Count Olaf
theatre troupe who is your favorites I
got a soft spot for uh for hook-handed
man because he's was he's like my right
hook man
last question if you were willingly
going to visit a deserted island for a
few days if you don't have three things
with you what would you bring three
things on a deserted island a lighter or
an RV one of those phones that that you
can call people to save you luxury item
type I bring I don't know a ukulele no
knowing on bite you
[Music]
maybe a flashlight all right those are
all my questions thank you for asking
them and thanks to all these puppies who
are all available if you want forever to
uh I don't want to be easy
they're all from the North Shore Animal
League so thanks to the amazing people
there for doing that and come and get
yourself oh no it's crazy you can't have
pit bulls in England if they consider
dangerous dogs which is just nonsense
look at this thing how could you say
that this is dangerous
[Music]
father
[Music]
we definitely do have a group chat it's
called the Holy Trinity Jacob and I met
at Jacobs audition obviously and artis
is the two puppies have the best smell
man
they're just that puppy smell there's
nothing like it oh we instantly became
really good friends and then when I
introduced him to my breast for
inheriting it was a power that we were
gonna be really good friends and that
and that sort of sparked this online
thing with the Holy Trinity sorry that
was a terrible answer I can't think
right now too distracted by the cuteness
of this little puppy right
Chris Pratt because I get tired and he's
so big he could carry me around
sorry again I forgot the question I'm
just - Vince these puppies right now
Kevin can we have some more puppies in
there I think we should bring all the
other puppies in and we should
definitely rip up the paper three movies
primal fear I think my cousin Vinnie and
spider-man homecoming so I can reminisce
all the good times I would choose
Atlantis and what
not the doctor dude the you are a little
nippy one yeah I probably play in the
explora
well I guess you don't really need to
ask for advice from these guys because
you can just watch them work and see how
the best in the business
do it
I would probably be a stuntman I would
never have known about the stuntman
world if I had been an actor first or a
carpenter maybe my family our
conferences or maybe a puppy Wrangler I
seem like I'm pretty good 20 keys are in
here I tried my first Twinkie the other
day and it was disgusting and I'll never
eat one again
and I actually got a lot of hate online
for not enjoying a Twinkie I was like
guys that's a bit me I think with great
power comes great responsibility
is the best quote I can give you hey
guys so this lovely interview today the
puppies have been brought to us by Angel
City pit bulls and you can pick up one
of these incredibly cute and really
noisy pit bull puppies puppies hundred
years from now what would you want
people to think of when they hear BTS
tune with the pain unit on stage pjsalt
I'm gonna get done imagine Reza and we
see John laughing at the views
sorry if you can't go back to when you
first debut do what would you tell
yourself would you change anything my
name if you stood with Ronda my gigantic
balloon to andragogy right now oh hey
you nice
keep going to tell the English you heard
English yeah since your album is named
liver cell what is one thing each of you
love about yourself Cocteau sizzles Hana
Hana she need a magician fashion fashion
fashion fashion fashion my official
fashion I like my passion yeah passion
and passion hello poppy
he said you like his puppies and Jimmy
my to my handsome face
I love my my life Wow
yeah could you go that's awesome yeah
they're showing their territories by
peen
that's what we call puppies puppies what
do you want armies to take away from
this upcoming album
I mean to leave us here a moment ago
ivory starch I mean that mockery taxes
or each of your favorite songs of up
love yourself to you but I've always
condoms wanna go home man I know she'll
hey Bobby what's your favorite thing so
what so what
yeah yeah yeah someone was singing to
you yeah how do you guys decide on the
things for your album oh oh I'm sorry
puppy album and music videos and been
the world as high as I am in a beautiful
cotton ball to get so much more than the
you how much your opinion on her to pay
dirt also mr. ban with mr. Baine talk
about next album it's been a long time
since you have a hot doctor how are you
guys getting use to it
what's been your favorite hair color so
you Modi homesick I'm Giovanni I was in
the army throat um but it didn't wash in
a job just right just black yeah I'm red
red red I love red hair honey you go to
one my neighbor Sunday
aw ha started the commuter come out it
wrote about him yes I like pick a color
you like pink yeah I like silver yellow
oh that's a Jae ho how did it feel to
receive such a positive reaction and
success when you're mixing hope where
can we expect more solid music in the
future jokes it makes a whole deal I
couldn't get on this one on rotation
just watch on Christian in the comeback
even there
well koutoubia maka way to get around
falafel the mocha ladies I don't have a
comfortable actually Lamar girl how did
you got cotton go up to give an entire
iPad in water for a protocol watching
roni eimacher guava on the river really
prefer makan Tomita next mixtape jk jk
really secured anything damn de nada
you guys I'm just me
hi I'm Natalie Portman and I'm here to
answer your questions while playing with
puppies cuties
[Music]
I'm really proud of my kids
they're really incredible in terms of
work I'm proudest of directing my phone
until 11:00 darkness and adapting it I
would love to direct another film I
don't have a particular plan it's kind
of in the creative phase of figuring
that out but yes I would love to direct
again and they will take a question
maybe V for Vendetta
in a buddy cop movie tip Haddish thankee
the thing I'd want people don't come
away from eating animals seeing is that
factory farming is really like the the
vast majority of the way that our food
is raised and it's not good for our
planet it's not good for humans and it's
certainly not good for the animals so
looking for new ways of feeding
ourselves that doesn't have to destroy
living creatures and our planet for
screenwriters to really work on every
character having their own voice I think
sometimes you definitely see the
screenwriters voice in there but you
don't always see that the characters
have different voices themselves actors
um experience life because you want to
be painting from real experience not
from like watching other movies or TV
shows or some things so it's important
to have a lot of life experience go out
live try things well read Black Swan
because of course I met my husband there
so I would relive that any day dinner
with my family
wine definitely wine yeah I'm red yes
oh so many so many I have many friends
who I'd like to work with like America
Ferrera and I sort of worked with
rashida Jones Julianne Moore Cate
Blanchett Isabel repair there's a lot I
kind of want to work with actresses in
general we rarely get to work together
[Music]
sure but my character did die so it
would take some narrative narrative
creativity for sure well you need to get
a little teat and wait well definitely
the pag my outfits were more comfortable
the Queen outfits had some heavy head
wear that was very beautiful very
beautiful constructive but not as
comfortable one strange Rock the
National Geographic show I'd really like
to travel and Southeast Asia like
Cambodia allows like backpack through
their Bhutan you are so delicious I like
yes these dogs are off from the
Vanderpump Rescue Foundation you can
learn more about how do I got them at
Vanderpump dogs org hi I'm Hilary Duff
and I'm at BuzzFeed I'm here to do an
interview no no no
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
you can't answer questions when there's
puppies do you plan on writing any more
books in the future and what are you
reading nowadays I don't I don't have
any plans to write any books it was one
of the hardest things I've ever done and
right now I just finished a book called
pachinko which I loved
it was very ambitious for me it was like
five of these pages and now I'm reading
a book called I see you look at this
copy body
what's one childhood teenage experience
you feel like you missed out on I never
got to have braces and I never got to
have a locker it's two things I really
was desperate for would you ever do a
Lizzie McGuire reboot honestly the idea
sounded terrible like two years ago when
we when reboots were happening but you
never know I don't know I loved I loved
Lizzie McGuire and it might be really
fun to see where she is now hey get out
of me fishbowl do you still know the
monologue from the locker room scene in
a Cinderella story is it like something
about waiting for you is like waiting
for the rain and a drought I've seen
little like memes that's why I know if
you could have one normal day to
yourself without any paparazzi or fans
what would you do I'd probably go to the
beach and I would just be with my kids
we're so used to it now but it is not
the fans of paparazzi kind of inevitable
Mouse so that would be nice to just have
a day where he's not aware and I'm not
aware and Miwa tries to probably go
about into normal stuff are you team
Josh or Team Charles and why I'm team
Josh always team Josh once Charles and
Liza finally bone and get it over with
like what are they gonna still gonna
talk about books all day I wish that you
guys could watch this and like get the
smells as like additional sensations
it's so cute
did you or anyone else ever get hit with
the giant red balls and the Lizzie
McGuire opening credits scene yes all
day long giant red balls is flying at
you at what moment did you realize you
were actually famous oh I know the exact
moment Lizzie McGuire aired and that
weekend I went to go meet my friends at
the mall and I literally had to hide in
a janitor's closet it was like the
craziest thing
I had to call my mom from the plot like
someone who worked at the mall was like
getting me in a closet and my mom had to
come and pick me up it was really crazy
it was actually a little scary you this
tiny little nook is so fun to see you
and your little heart is just pounding
you're so cute if you have to give your
younger cast members in your books super
what is superlative guys didn't go to
high school like what's that Nico would
be the biggest flirt for sure Miriam
would be the class clown I think
probably Kelsey would be like prom queen
did I do that math okay which one of
your songs could you listen to on repeat
if you had to and which one would you
want to erase from your memory my
boyfriend brought it up the other day he
was like you know what's a fat song wake
up wake up was the back dog it was so
cute like you know that one from the
newer album I loved spark the single it
was really fun
there's a lot on metamorphosis that I
wish I could forget but then so many
people come up to me they're like that
happens every week and they always call
out the most embarrassing someone it's
like there's a song called the max and I
don't get it at all that's like one of
my most embarrassing moments in life so
probably a lot from that record hard to
choose really what is your favorite
Lizzie McGuire episode and which episode
han-soo to this day my favorite episode
is I want to bra a bra bra bra first of
all I think filming it was absolutely
mortifying for me excite probably had
just gone to bra and real life anyway
but when I watch it back I like that
it's so funny what if this all went to
[ __ ] and I started getting like beat up
off my the copy this is like the best
thing ever I think everybody she gets to
play with puppies no matter what their
job this is so happy this is so funny
honestly this is the best treat ever
guys all of these puppies are for
adoption through the North Shore Animal
League America who wouldn't want to play
with this all day oh yes they love it
[Music]
2015 party his thought was a party and
my absolute favorite song would have to
be into the new world because that's
what it started the story it's for
everyone about finally being comfortable
in your own skin I wanted to bring all
the things I loved about kpop and all
the things I loved about the pop I grew
up to and for an album yes I'm hoping to
continuously put up music and hopefully
have a body of work to share for my fans
[Music]
there was like fantastic friends here
were like we can call him fanny pack
sounds like oh my god no but there are
some really really fun and creative
names so I'm really looking forward to
what the fans come up with so let me
know what you guys they don't say fanny
pack I am a huge fan of the Lion Heart
talk dog because I had a lot of input on
that all of that song I looked so much
that I performed at my solo concert like
on an acoustic version sorry to
disappoint but nope actually they said
if she doesn't pick the Lion Heart top
top we don't know her
so yes you do know me
[Music]
to her outfit and then feel like
everybody's like yes that was not the
pink we thought we were getting and then
it was like fluorescent almost obnoxious
pink I mean everything is a challenge
but growing up in front of the camera my
bandmates and I were talking about
certain things and then they're like wow
we cooked really well and I was like
yeah pat on the back to everybody going
up would probably be one of the toughest
things but I'm here at this interview I
made it I feel like I probably be doing
the art side or the behind-the-scenes
side to music or fashion or or puppies I
guess I'm getting both worlds where I
get to come here and say I'm thinking
and creating cuz it I was always
thinking in English when I was in Korea
but I guess I'm I'm flexing both muscles
[Music]
my secret is having just as comfortable
shoes when I'm off of them and balancing
cuz you can guess it's unreal my
choreographers in real
mind control oh my gosh I look so creepy
baby wait so does that make me professor
Eric yeah thank you
call me professor T little mermaid is
everything because morals and values
were built on Disney you know being in a
world where you think you had everything
and everyone tells you that you should
thought you should believe what they're
saying but you believe in the bigger
world and you go out of your comfort
zone for love and I think that's an
amazing story and it's ironic because
I'm scared of fish eyes weird right no
side eyes fell from aerial puffle I
pushed it because you loved all of them
but I did get to meet Victoria Beckham
she told me about she said yeah being in
a girl band is amazing you create family
from that and I was like you're right I
love all of you yes I love them all it
was during their interview I was like
yeah you need to see her and she's like
I'm not that desperate and it was a joke
but I guess the fans love when we say
like pretty intense keywords and that's
why they're like yeah Tansen desperate
and she posted a support post on my song
she put like every pink emoji there was
and that takes a lot of time in court
and then the fans are like yeah totally
that's right I was like no she just
loves me we love each other yes we were
desperate for each other does that clear
everything these adorable puppies are
available for adoption at
Animal Society
[Music]
sup guys bury me with the puppy shall we
name the dogs I think he or she okay
what concept more music Jenner what do
you like to try in the future she did
she didn't have a wooden tongue in our
concept rock rock to jazz no do you
don't chip Baker - yeah I know oh you
want to pick it was mistakes to be
remembered more security keota symmetric
in denial powerful powerful energetic
good senior a respectful city er sexy
cool vice handsome savage rubbish
Jane picks one yeah oh how do you feel
you grow as an artist between your first
and second world wars I wanted to
whatever the clothes i yeah i just wrote
to get something about the kitchen I
think I remember this verse 60 and more
good English better more small change a
little we locked a little bit
well apparently as a bangle wreckage of
to general one and what honey I want all
the play with dogs he's not coming if
you could do collaboration with any
other celebrity either solo or as a
group who would if the Hoover so Kincaid
or selenium Mayo these puppies if
there's one thing you could change from
your past what would you eat be positive
abortion push me later
yeah your name a new present was from
the past and the future comes from the
present so I like my stuff right now
I agree you to have me to know to them
to get a working for chew on and I am
all what are some of your favorite
lyrics that you've written Joshua I'm
shaky compassion for children cars on
bottom a student cousin and watching by
oh oh I like my rattler exchange type
forever because my lyrics are destroyer
like belief rap yeah I like it if you
could switch bodies with one member for
a day it be and why out of my own pocket
cigar see Tammy on all the member
acordes yourself oh there's a good buddy
thank you
hey focus on me I'm sorry concentrate I
want Wallace body why the car I want
hey focus on
I want to ask you have no just one okay
do you have any tips on how to address
well like all of you what do you own
sexism do you without detroit remember
joe said 'god don't cheer peppa pig out
turn in people about you yes sir follow
me come on Tess
mix kitchen exquisite you attend a new
trigger their worship or Harry Potter Oh
100%
Terry book Twilight vampire you cannot
pick it up oh that's question it is
first shuttle shuttle Jess what do you
like about being the leader over boom
states versus the do those items are the
two top leaders a fan jump
haha I think I'm just leader
yeah oh so energetic just so cute I want
at the Vista let's go home together you
can't adopt this cute puppies I know
what sure animal II America hi guys I
know I said today I'm a film called
Sarah bridges hi Jeff Bridges is a loser
I'll be answering some fan questions at
play with the pups this is the best day
[Music]
there's a part in the film where this
kid and the band is supposed to be
screaming like screaming my name
he's like Jamie Jamie but he was like he
went a little he went a little off the
edge with the rule and there's a blooper
reel somewhere where he's like screaming
profanities and he's like hey Oh James
James and he's like freaking out and
it's the funniest thing
[Music]
you know there's a lot of great messages
in Sarah Burgess one of them is
definitely don't let people eat your
ears one of them is don't let society
dictate what beauty is that's a really
important one another one is there's
really cool part where the bully
Veronica and Shannon or Sierra they kind
of get together in their enemies at
first but then they become really good
friends and that's their understanding
each other and I think that's a huge
huge takeaway which is like yes someone
could be your enemy but you can't really
judge someone until you know who they
are why they are the way they are and
it's kind of hard to not like someone
when you understand that I have it
happened like a year and a half ago I've
met someone on Instagram and like I
dislike ostensibly intimate relationship
with them and then turns out they
weren't who they were as TAF phishing
does
I learned some of it during the process
of filming I don't speak it I don't sign
but it was definitely really really
quite an experience getting to know more
about the community and the culture of a
signing I'd say I'm closer to you by
this tail I'm closer to Jamie all my
day-to-day life no doubt and then
sometimes I can be a little PD okay why
not when Mike calls for it a little more
aggressive or more egotistical for short
you're never second best yeah this chick
is so kind and so talented Wow I'm lucky
to be here it's pretty much how that
went and I was like that the rest of the
shoot she does these little like like
there's a little facial expressions like
[Music]
no way that hmm it's kind of my best
I've really bad at impressions I really
like the kitchen scene between Lara Jean
and Peter at Peter's kitchen when they
are kind of opening up to each other
about their family history I got it the
same principle of like understanding why
people are the way they are yeah it was
really great to shoot on it such an
excellent talented giving actress
I used to do it with a my girlfriends in
fact I would like I would totally do
that and it's just it was very cute I
think I think maybe once or twice they
were in the script but I say well we'll
all the time
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay relax
this one I got attacked by a dog
are these mastiff babies oh yeah I get
attacked when I was six years old by a
mastiff he ripped a hole in my face so
you could see my teeth my gums and all
the way through my tongue to the other
side there's just a massive gaping hole
I specifically remember him lunging and
like being pulled away from him and then
looking back and seeing him like he like
cocked his head like he didn't really
understand what had happened some people
were like yeah do you want to put the
dog down I was like crying I was like no
no he didn't mean to do it
my parents got a dog for us a black lab
German Shepherd Rottweiler mix them
Mackenzie like 6 weeks after the event
and then getting another dog like a
bigger dog after that was like great you
know a bigger dog you better Shantaram
like Gregory David Roberts the whole
book is very poetic and it's a it's a
journey from deep diving into the abyss
and then coming back from it and
transcending it was changing and
learning and it's a beautiful read right
now all I can think about is the fact
that they're both making out with my
father I used to suck my thumb to I used
to do all the time
it's a suckable thumb
[Music]
let me do this I would say I don't know
I guess I wouldn't give any advice to
the iSchool me outside
you know what no yeah well I would have
said don't shut down so much after after
kids were addicted you don't like hide
who you are and maybe if I hadn't built
up such high walls who knows what would
have been different but I'm very I'm
pretty pretty fortunate and pretty like
grateful for the way that my life's
turned out excuse me you guys are
adorable in case you didn't know okay
[Music]
sorry Kravitz I love you where did these
puppies so much wire
[Music]
hey shower water and then I like dry it
and I just shake it whenever we were
doing like stuff like this so I can talk
to you guys there's like this spray this
like sea salt spray so what is it sea
salts great that like makes it look like
I just got out the ocean yeah it's all
fake
[Music]
I'm not really romantic um that's not
true
I can I can remember a time where I like
took this girl back to her hometown and
we like did a whole like week and a half
vacation I've written like a good amount
of love letters for sure I'm sorry I
know you don't want to be here and I
know I'm not the cutest person ever but
I love you it's a plan signior like on
the iPhone when you're gonna watch one
of your one of your your videos on your
your camera roll it's just the black
with the play circle around it I changed
it because I had a picture of my
ex-girlfriends on it like almost a year
ago and I was like I keep thinking about
it whenever I open my phone so I just
changed it to that and it's great now I
don't even think about it like I don't
even register that I'm looking at a
picture when I opened my phone which is
one less thing to like think about a
thousand times a day cuz you open your
phone with others but these dogs these
are beautiful creatures right here I
provided by Vanderpump dogs Vanderpump
dogs dogs org very durable Vanderpump
dogs
[Music]
stop stop hey this is not acceptable
you do not hump your brother it's the
girl upping the guy I like you killing
it
yeah big dick energy you know uh hi I'm
Dinah rackleff I am here with BuzzFeed
and I am going to be answering some
questions while I play with some puppies
bringing the puppies
he's so green and fluffy yeah Wow hind
legs straight away a theme of lifespan
of a fact it's fact versus fiction what
is the craziest rumor you've ever heard
about yourself I heard that I had got
the SAS to work my dog's the most elite
military force in the UK I also heard
that I was having beer brewed by monks
in Belgium in a monastery especially
because I'm so specific about the beer I
like it was other than a drink in years
at this point that's what I thought was
there did you keep anything from the
Harry Potter set yes I did keep the
glasses from the Harry Potter I kept one
pair of glasses and I thinking like
other little bits and pieces props that
I stole along the way can you explain
where you don't really use social media
yeah because it seems really stressful I
never see somebody going oh I just
checked my Twitter and this great thing
happened or like I can't wait to get
onto Facebook tonight and I it would
just be another thing to do I can barely
keep up with email like um I'm quite
happy to just like see my friends when I
see them and what's happened in their
life will be a surprise rather than
something I read about already
oh that's that's not the kind of thing
rushing to Jimmy tip cuz he's got a
white tip on his tail
Susanna and Florence who knows why what
is your go-to karaoke song the real Slim
Shady
I probably shouldn't mention it because
now people will go to that YouTube video
but it exists so you would have found it
anyway eventually with death in Harry
Potter was the hardest for you to get
over was serious definitely was was also
because it meant ie at the time like I
didn't know if I'd be working with Gary
Oldman again and that was very sad and I
adored Gary and working with him was an
incredibly formative experience in my
life the character's death has come so
out of the blue as well it's like yeah
that was a real shocker when are you and
Elijah would finally gonna do a project
about brothers or mistaken identity
what is that dance you're doing that's
great I don't know I would love to do
something with Elijah Wood where we play
brothers I know if he'd be up for it but
I can only speak myself but I'm I'm I'm
on board
whoever wrote that question you go write
the script what is your favorite thing
about being on Broadway I sound like a
cheesy answer but like the Broadway
community as a whole they just want to
you know and get you into the into the
community and make you feel welcome when
is the last time you watched a Harry
Potter movie I think maybe a mere but
maybe at the premiere of the last one
I've seen bits and pieces of them since
what is this why the growler
okay alright yeah I have a level who was
your celebrity crush growing up I mean
Arif you the first like picture of a
girl I sort of had like poster ago I had
on my wall was
was Cameron Diaz I was pretty infatuated
by kirsten dunst after I saw actually
I'll get over it and then I'll fry sauce
spider-man those are the two yeah that
upside that whole upside-down kiss my
think that's that that that was a moment
for a lot of us instead of poppies which
matter cook magical creature would you
want to play with while you answer fan
questions if you could dragons I don't
want to answer fan questions while I'm
playing with dragons else oh that's a
very rude question to ask in front of
the puppies please but if you could have
one whole egg from the wizarding world
what would it be maybe just like the the
Holograms of myself because I find it
quite creepy and would rather I
contained it's not the rest of the world
what is the best personal or career
advice you have ever gotten my dad gave
me a great piece of advice once which is
when you meet people to get your hand
out first I guess like create an
impression of enthusiasm for me people
and it gets you off on the right foot
and yeah I've always sort of done that
and stuck to it and it's so far you know
I think it's yeah that's a good one
it is adopter shelter built month all of
these amazing adorable puppies who do
not want to sit in my lap right now from
the ASPCA and if you would like help
finding a home for one of these
fantastic and wriggly but very cute dogs
go to ASPCA org /a find your Fido to
give one of these wonderful creatures a
home and you don't have to give them the
names I did you can find them this has
been fantastic fun thank you very much
for watching thank you very much for
your questions
and please if you are so inclined come
and see the show lifespan of a fact at
Studio 54 thanks very much and see you
next time world's world's next time hey
I'm Kasey Musgraves and I'm here at
BuzzFeed I'm gonna answer your questions
and play with some puppies
all right bring him on in oh my god hey
friend come here come here
oh my good you like my hairspray all
right first question what's something
texted nevermind what is the story of
the first time you ever smoked the
devil's lettuce I was in high school and
we were all hanging out with this guy
named sprinkles and I tried it and it
didn't do anything and I was like this
is boring hey oh oh you're the one who
just urinated why are you wet
what do you think about Lady gaga and
are you going to see a star as worn yeah
I'm gonna go I'm going tonight I think
she's very talented and I'm excited to
see movie I have a lot of friends that
wrote songs to the movie so I'm excited
to see how those turned out what do you
think of candy corn I think it's pretty
what do you think of candy corn is that
your name your name what city are you
most excited to visit on your upcoming
tour I really like Copenhagen and I've
never gotten to play a show there I've
just kind of rolled through it and it's
super unique and fun I'm excited about
that answer day hey you I want you I
mean this one is kind of like the mature
one of the group I think I think he's
look at this one oh man if you had the
opportunity to say something a Donald
Trump to his face what would you say I
don't know hopefully I'm never that
close who came up with the idea to sing
you're still the one at Madison Square
Garden night too
when you're on tour with Harry Caray
well I did text me when I said we should
do it Shanaya song and he makes that one
what's your go-to karaoke song um I
really like goodbye roll by the Dixie
Chicks
I love skater boy after living I love
any Celine Dion specifically my heart
will go on or that's the way it is of
all the famous people you've met who is
exactly like we thought they'd be funny
timing for this because a few days ago
I got something Adele for the first time
and she was exactly like you think she
would be just open the door with no
makeup and um just was really like kind
and open-hearted and funny profane and
seemingly like unaffected by all of our
success and I really admire those
qualities and it was really fun I love
her do you believe in ghosts yeah deaf
there's probably someone here right now
but it's a more fun world for me to like
imagine that there's like a spirit of
spiritual side of things oh my god it's
a little literally tornado of puppies
will we ever find out who high horse is
about calling up it's about a lot of
people though actually like multiple
being attacked help me no no just
kidding okay so this one says you've
recently been vocal about the lack of
inclusivity for female country music
artists what do you think it will take
to turn the tide and get country music
back to a time where women roll like the
time of Loretta and Tammy and Dolly well
I'm not sure we'll ever really get back
to the time of Loretta and Tammy and
Ellie that was an anomaly that will
never happen again
I don't know you know there's so much
focus on gender equality and country
music and it's such a tiring subject for
me because to me there's so many areas
of inequality in country music that I
want to see change happen in I think
there should be more country artists of
color I think there should be country
artists you know that are representing
the LGBTQ community from their
perspective and even just like Sonic's
differences like in songs aren't allowed
really to be that popular a lot of
things like sound the same and so it's
not just gender it's a lot of things
subject matter in equality I mean
hopefully over time that that will open
and if not then people will turn
elsewhere for to find the music that
inspires them what's your favorite
Britney Spears song email my heart just
kidding not that one
a lot of toxic Oh what's your Hogwarts
house that's a good question I just
recently got in a Harry Potter on on the
late bloomer so it's what ravenclaw
hufflepuffs Slytherin fat Gryffindor I'm
gonna go for the classic Gryffindor like
that's what that's the house you wanted
me if not that then maybe like Ravenclaw
it helps to plus like a bunch well there
is just like that's a negative zone
what's been your favorite song to
perform I love singing slow burn for
some reason I have a big connection to
this song it feels very personal to me
and whatever key it's in is like really
comfortable for me to sing so it just
feels like water like flowing I don't
know it just feels really good I don't
have to push but it's always fun singing
like merry-go-round arrow because like
everyone else words best thing about
being married knowing that no matter
what somebody has your back and that you
have somebody else's back it's a really
wonderful feeling and I genuinely never
thought that I would get married I was
that person it was like I did not see
this happening for myself then the right
person came along and just like I knew
right away that it was that he was right
and it's awesome we we support each
other and it's hard sometimes because
we're both artists and we're about to
not see each other for Wow but but it
bought it um cool well we have one more
question is Oh rank your top three
condiments sriracha sriracha and
sriracha and get mustard and mayo away
from me I don't even want to don't even
try to put that on my sandwich thank you
so much it's been so much fun all of
these puppies are available for adoption
from North Shore Animal League America
I'm Kacey Musgraves thanks so much for
watching
hey I'm Tiffany Haddish and I'm doing a
puppy interview for BuzzFeed G ready you
gonna just have the puppies at the
beginning alright let's go
what up dog hey I like the pit
let's keep these party started hey puppy
[Music]
alright so considering your difficult
pass what advice would you give to young
kids who have big dreams but feel stuck
I would say move forward figure out what
it is that you love to do stay focused
stay focused stay focused do one thing
every day towards your goal and get the
you will get you no matter how bad
something is right now that means a son
good on the other side of that bag
like if a pup you take a poop right now
I know that somebody in here got a
plastic bag to get that poop up and get
it out of here see how they go what's
your favorite quality about yourself and
what's one thing you're insecure about I
would say one of my favorite qualities
about me is my boobie I heard you like
my butt and one of the things I'm
insecure about is my eyebrows which
shows are you currently obsessed with
right now I'm currently obsessed with
reruns
sheera and he-man I like the Smurfs also
I like watching I like watching an
empire and yes I'm obsessed with reruns
of pound puppies what movie genre would
you do outside of comedy and why what's
primer gangster movies you know I'm
doing a romantic comedy right now I do a
romantic drama love stories I would love
to do document documenting type of
movies like we're not documenting movies
what's the what you call that when you
do somebody life story
life story movies alright build a
playlist
songs for when you you're feeling sad I
like to play upbeat music to change that
emotion so you know some like Sierra be
on stage some James Brown you know I
played that kind of music when I'm from
the [ __ ] cuz then that race was that my
vibration I don't like to be sad when
I'm ready to party I play something I
say so I'm Sierra Snoop Dogg some you
know some to my proof yes and thinking
of BAE when I'm thinking of a dude I
like the players from Erica if I do some
Maxwell some some Marvin Gaye something
yes you're good doggy fine
I don't have no snacks if I have snacks
hey I don't kiss I don't kiss everybody
in the mouth you used to work as an
energy producer what but what puts you
in a really good mood things that put me
in a really good mood my thoughts you
coming up a [ __ ] lip okay
who was your favorite actor slash
actress to work with so far and who was
the most difficult to work with my most
favorite actor/actress to work with thus
far is um the cats from Keanu movie I
was in
with Jordan Peele the cat her name is
Clementine she now lives with me she's
amazing to work with and to live with
and the worst to work with was a baby
that was in it scene I don't remember
that baby name I just know that baby was
not a good baby if you had a superpower
what would be your kryptonite cheese I
can't stand cheese I mean because I
something some kind of cheeses I like
but then all of them mess my stomach up
that's some time
I'm not sitting anyways just to humble
myself
what's one skill you wish you possessed
or wish you were better I wish I possess
the skill of talking to animals I can
talk to them but I'm not good at it see
I wish I was better anywhere I get them
to talk back we working on me what do
you think would be your job if you
weren't an actress or comedian I would
be a sex education teacher because I
think that is very important to teach
people had to have proper sex okay
chilla okay I heard you were fluent in
Japanese is that true hey you home girl
got school she want cutting mice guys
tell us your worst first date story we
don't got time for that
we'll just say this okay a man's car
stank alright it's at its day I don't
let me and pick me up for dates
I need them there because I did not want
all show that happy to try to hump me
that happens too they try to hump me for
no I was like Hello we and Chili's why
are you trying to hump me in the Chili's
stop it
who is your celebrity crush and what
would you do if you met them I have met
my celebrity crushes
there are several left and when I met
them I ask them on a date ask them if I
could cook for them as the [ __ ] of rub
on their bodies they all turn me down
Trevor Noah
I could be joined one more question this
is the last one guys come on in bring it
in bring it in okay stay there you
you're the best
what was the glue is the last coupon you
purchased an adult toy because I broke
the last one I'm not really dating right
now we have to do what we have to do I
like to call it safe sex and nobody does
it like me make sure you go see nobody's
fool in theaters November the second
okay and just in case you were wondering
all these puppies are adoptable from
North Shore Animal League check them out
North Shore Animal League they have
really great puppies shoot you might
find a man there you know what I'm gonna
go visit North Shore Animal League and
see who worked it may be my future man
is deep who knows
do y'all hi you're single dude okay
looks like I'm going to North's store
animal need to find me a real dog what's
up guys I'm Sabrina carpenter I'm here
at BuzzFeed and I'm here to answer some
of your questions oh my goodness are you
bringing in a lot of puppies right now
hi kids
hey this is amazed how many are there oh
my goodness let's begin you gonna grab
some for me eat them alrighty one was a
time that you were starstruck when I met
lin-manuel Miranda I don't know why I
felt unworthy I couldn't speak when I
met him for some reason and I was so
uncool about it what's your dream acting
role I would probably be to star in a
movie with a lot of dogs so that way I
could do this on set every day also a
dream role that I've always wanted I've
always wanted to do a
musical I've always wanted to collide
those tools that I have it I'd like to
do an action film that would be really
cool is yours on Paris about a real
relationship yes there's so many times
in my life where we're focused on
something else that we're missing what's
right in front of us but right now is
not one of those times I'm very focused
on what's in front of me and not worried
about owning anything else in the future
and so yeah these are that question
you're eating my heel that's cool okay
we're gonna go to the next one what was
your reaction when you were chosen to be
part of the hate you give had you
already read the book I had already read
the book and I was very very excited
because I knew that it was going to be
an incredibly important movie and now
that I have been a part of it and I've
seen the movie multiple times it is one
of the most emotional experiences and
rollercoasters I think I've ever been
through in my life these are very deep
philosophical questions to be in a room
surrounded by puppies I'm I'm not very
focused right now this is a good one do
you prefer cheese or chocolate chocolate
right once I did an interview in a ball
pit but I'd like to say I have a lot
more going on here I think I like dogs
better than halls I was quite a sound
bite wasn't it yes you are stuck on a
desert island and can only pick one of
your co-stars to be with you who do you
pick ooh
[Music]
I feel like my
friend and co-star danielle fishel would
be very good to have on island with me
because she's very smart I feel like we
would get out of the island if I was
with Danielle you know Danielle has a
dog named brunch I could introduce you
guys if you would like what would 19
year old Sabrina say to 12 year old
Sabrina be a little more selective about
what you post on the Internet
you're not gonna like it all later
you're not gonna like most of it later
[Music]
if you start in a rom-com who would you
want to play your co-star I would want
you to be my co-star can you be my
co-star in a rom-com I really do
celebrity crushes I feel like I was just
talking the other day though about how I
once went up to Zac Efron when I saw him
on the beach and I was 11 and I told him
that I liked his work and he wasn't
wearing his shirt and that's how
composed I was as an 11 year old I said
I'm a big fan of your work
and he was so nice to me but I just like
remember being that nerd at 11 years old
if you could sing or act with any
celebrity past or present who would it
be and why I would want to sing with
Paul McCartney and I would want to add
Judy Garland if I were to name them you
would be Budweiser just ain't no
laughter but you would be Dos Equis you
would be Coors Light you would be Diet
Coke and then you would be Chandler Bing
I'm not a Monica though I'm I think I'm
more of a Rachel or Phoebe would be your
dream collaboration yes just eat it I
already know the question now here's the
thing is
such a hard question because I have so
many I don't feel like I could choose
one but I do I really do love I'm a big
fan of Rockhampton I'm a big big fan of
Rihanna my fans know that and I love
Adele I really love Adele where did the
name singular come from listen up kids
so I named my new album singular because
I felt like after I had kind of tied up
the album writing process I'd gone back
in list you can be free for a minute
you've been with me the whole time or no
come back okay after I kind of tied up
the album writing process I'd gone back
and listened to a lot of my favorite
songs and realized that this overall
theme for the album was this unspoken
confidence I was talking to someone who
had listened to the album and one of the
words that they used to describe it was
singular and it stuck in that moment I
didn't look back and I'm very happy I
didn't I haven't wanted to change it
even though I've had it for a while I
just felt like the right the right thing
you've now worked with two of the
Riverdale stars KJ and Casey kaat are
you a fan of the show I'm a fan of both
of them and I have I watched the whole
first season I I'm very bad at finish
trick shows so I'm still in the second
season but they're so talented
tell us what singular means to you in
three words
I'd say my next chapter I'd say it's a
part of my life that I will never ever
forget and I'm creating new memories
with it every day starting right now I
know that all I'll look back and I'll
think so many things about this album
and where I was at this point in my life
but I definitely will never forget it
and it'll always be that thing that
takes me to where I'm going next
empty jar and the puppies still on my
lap that means I'm taking it home I love
you Chandler being yo y'all really know
how to do it that's all I'm gonna say
y'all really just know how to make
someone's day I top it out today I don't
care I got puppies I got so many dogs
around me do you see this smile I never
smile like this ever thank you guys so
much it's been so much fun make sure to
check out my new album singular act one
and I can't wait to be back soon and my
standards are pretty high now all these
puppies are up for adoption at North
Shore Animal League America but they say
what look they're just bite me hey
so I'm Michael B Jordan and I'm just
hanging out here at BuzzFeed answering
some fan questions and I was trying to
think of something I could do while I
was answering these questions and I say
you know what let's bring in the puppies
[Music]
West is going alright let's come up here
together push sob what is going on
gonna help me answer some questions huh
good one
let me think blade top of my head the
training process and crew - was pretty
intense I kind of knew what to expect
already went through the first time on
Creed one cardio swimming weight lifting
diet and I have not kept up with the
workouts you know right after I got
finished doing Creed - I shot this other
movie called just mercy playing a lawyer
and I dropped weight but I'm getting
back hey these are ones okay
these are breads you will learn okay
Jordan wines is precious you don't bite
these I was in Philly so cheesesteak huh
what's that cheese dick yes it depends
on what albums out I'm very much so the
person of you know whatever album's
going on I'll burn that one over and
over and over and over and over again so
I think when I was shooting creep - ah
that's me that's me alright so I think
Nipsey Hussle
victory lap had just drops all this - a
lot of Nipsey Hussle
[Music]
I don't know that's above my pay grade
but I love Marvel you know I love like I
love that character so yeah be able to
kind of like team up with like what's uh
Chadwick and Marvel and and Ryan and be
able to say I won't separate you two
hey hey are you calm down buddy good all
right to be able to kind of give back on
setting work with them again would be
would be a lot of fun but who knows it's
tough because everybody's been you know
on their own careers and you know making
great films and television shows and
stuff like that but I definitely catch
up with their work you know being able
to see you know like Jesse Plemons on
black mirror and and be ever seen couch
and lit hey those two yeah look Donna's
then in rings grab it and you see
everybody kind of grow over the years
and uh you know have careers of it you
know that that that's that took off and
become very successful is it's exciting
to kind of see them progress cuz we all
kind of came from that Friday night's
family I never wanted to be an actor
growing up there was something that kind
of chose me but over the years I think
learning the power of cinema
you know storytelling can make people
think you know and feel and ask
questions yeah all of those reasons kind
of why I fell in love with acting
overtime and they decided to you know
make it a career
I don't know now they're checking out a
lot checking off a lot of my boxes and
maybe like some type of like Jason's
Lorne double-oh-seven give me a gun in
the suit cars international blowing some
stuff up but with heart and character
and story not just a you know a cheesy
film I want to do something that it
makes you think it makes you feel so a
project around that
any word anime I think I'm gonna go with
hmm hey what's up which one an epoch huh
I'm saying the road says why because I
love you know Japanese culture I love to
kind of be able to play in that world
and mixture between old-school ninjas
and and and and seals and and
friendships and bonds and all the things
that they kind of put into the road soo
- oh I think that'll be pretty cool hey
hey I've seen the road - how I want to
stay in the road - these puppies were
provided by Pacific pups rescue
executive a guy so guys want a dog
little fawn check them out what's up
guys I'm Alessia Cara and I'm here to
talk about my album the pains of growing
with some really beautiful puppies he
hates me already
oh my goodness they don't know what to
do with themselves this one loves me
this one loves me hello who has been
your best and take me to dinner first
I met Oprah at a party - I'm an Oprah at
a party and it was right after I won the
Grammy and she spotted me and came up to
me and was like hi bosz new artist and i
free free Pete did he gave me like a
weird half-assed handshake once what
like before I was anybody ah
he's attacking me I think do you watch
YouTube if so what would you recommend I
do watch you - jenna Marbles and
Julian's fella Mita are amazing they
have a really cool podcast called J and
J podcast bellifiore is really great cuz
she does these like murder mystery
segments on her channel it's amazing and
any type of black head popping video how
do you get your curls to look so nice do
you have any product you could recommend
I think the key first of all it's a
curly hair or to getting it less frizzy
is drying your hair with a cotton
t-shirt instead of a towel now cotton
t-shirts just keeps all the moisture in
and don't make hair frizzy so that's
step number one and then you can use
some sort of sea salt spray I use a
coconut oil spray I think it's by
Moroccan oil I'm not quite sure I'll use
that and a diffuser diffuser is key it's
a little attachment that goes on the end
of your blow-dryer what was it like
performing and hanging out with Taylor
Swift it was a man she's so sweet and
really really nice and made me feel so
comfortable and my whole team and family
feel incredibly comfortable so that was
really fun hi oh my god
s marry collab with on the Hedgehog
Mendes Justin Bieber - okay well I can't
marry down there but I can't ask Justin
Bieber well no Justin Bieber's already
married so then maybe collab with Justin
Bieber
I can't f Shawn there I'm talking later
as if this is gonna happen I won't marry
both John Mayer and Shawn Mendes and
we'll have a nice little family
relationship a nice little polygamy
which artist inspired you growing up Amy
Winehouse Lauryn Hill Shania Twain
Erykah Badu's pink house Fame affected
your personal relationships I don't know
I think for the most part they've been
the same I think maybe the only
difference is that some people who I
didn't really know before or like some
random family members that I didn't
really talk to you before I have like
appeared but I think that's normally you
know and people even though you don't
talk to people for a while they're still
proud of you so I don't know I think
makes help people treat you a little bit
differently which is strange like I've
seen some people from school now that
like act like they've never known me and
they're like oh weird around me but
that's a little bit weird but for the
most part I don't know I think I stay
the same so the people around you kind
of stay the same
what does your favorite / Lee's favorite
song to perform and why I still love
performing here because it's fun and
then my least favorite is probably wild
things because I'm just screaming the
entire time and I'm sorry I just
recently heard the studio version for
the first time in a long time and I just
realized I'm screaming the entire time
so I'm sorry for yelling at all of you
guys in that song you seem so
down-to-earth and humble what are the
things that keep you grounded thank you
um those things that keep me grounded
are probably my morals and values I
value you know the idea of family and
the idea I just value being grounded I
value being a nice human being to other
people um and I have a really great
family and great people around me that
always keep me you know down-to-earth so
which song on the album was the hardest
to write and the easiest the hardest
ones are right I don't know I don't
usually keep the songs that are hard to
write to be honest but the easiest was
out of love it just came out very
quickly what are your thoughts on
Brendon Urie
oh I'm panic at the disco love them love
them so much I think he's such an
incredible performer and I think they're
amazing I saw him at the AMAs and they
were like this thick what's your
favorite Taylor Swift song oh ooh
hey Stephen Kleene speak now how do you
feel about pineapples on pizza
I don't mind it I'm neither I'm neither
here nor there with it I don't mind them
if they're on there but I don't think
it's necessary I'm not gonna order a
pineapple visa but I will eat one if
it's there are you trying to untie my no
no
how do you deal with the hate from your
haters I unleash puppies on them so okay
guys that was my interview with a bunch
of these beautiful puppies go soon
tomorrow when the panes are growing if
you haven't already he's he's a big fan
or she he is a big fan and all of these
lovely sweet puppies are adoptable from
North Shore Animal League America
they're so sweet and cute and you should
take one home because they need a home
and I wish I could take them all but I
can't so you should this is very wet hi
I'm Lea Manuel Miranda I'm here for Mary
Poppins returns I'm answering your fan
questions and look at this guy I'll be
play with puppies the whole time
oh I'm excited for audiences to see the
continuing Adventures of Mary Poppins to
see Michael and Jane Banks all grown up
and and Marc Shaiman and Scott Whitman's
incredible songs I feel like the best
thing they did was get the biggest super
fan of the original film Rob Marshall to
direct it because I think that
everything in here will make fans of the
original and there we having happening I
think the dancing I think I was pretty
funny baby I think I was pretty daunted
by step in time in the original and
we've got a number that's about as long
and as elaborate as that and so it was
the last thing we filmed and it was
about six months of rehearsal for it and
at the same time the level of mastery
going from just learning how to swing
around a lamppost and then suddenly
you're holding a flaming stick and
there's BMX bikers all around you
getting to that level of mastery just
was pretty satisfying right
oh there are totally different skill
sets you know acting on stage as a yoga
it's seven times a week eight times a
week and you're gonna hit the same marks
every night but the audience changes
your performance your energy that day
changes your performance and your
relationship to your fellow actors on
screen you're never coming back to
Buckingham Palace you're never coming
back to Big Bend so the adrenalin DUI
crackling comes from knowing that that's
your chance to get it right yeah sure
you well well there's two things
we actually I think I've said this but
we've we filmed the original company
about a week before the first cast
members started leaving and Tommy Kael
made an amazing movie out of it and we
stuck it in a vault and it's in a
basement of somewhere so at some point
you'll see that so if you have an
obnoxious friend who is bragging as well
the original company that brag is gonna
be out of use at some point you will see
them you just haven't decided when you
know I want as many people to get to see
it live in the original format in which
it was intended the theater before we
release it but we've got it it's a green
God's fault
[Music]
what's his puppy's name guppy oh my
goodness I'm holding Dudley I'm getting
licked by a real cute puppy oh wow Wow
we are just jamming Jesus Oh his breath
smells like salmon now he's biting up on
my finger doesn't really hurt I will not
let it linger
he's got puppy teeth then they are not
sharp I will not go to heaven I am NOT
playing a harp you can know on that it
does not hurt my pinky after this I'll
have a big gin and tonic drinky
[Music]
Brooklyn anger my favorite chef I hope
so I'm glad NBC picked it back up I
don't think I was but I was allowed a
part of it oh that's a fantastic
question I don't know the answer to that
either I think we'll find out you know
my favorite character was always
Sebastian he's really misunderstood
composer everyone forgets that but he's
the court composer and suddenly he's
babysitting the sixteen year old and and
that is so relatable for me you know
we're still very much in script
development things on on Little Mermaid
so if there needs to be a new song I'm
happy to write lyrics for Alan Menken
there doesn't need to be because that
score is perfect perfect I don't think
I'm gonna tell you the answer that
because I would want to surprise you
total eclipse of the heart and or I
would do anything for love but I won't
do that
it's very indulgent to take the light
for seven minutes what I say I would say
it's a long story here you're gonna be
mad about some of this and maybe some of
it you like but I have you win against
Jefferson a lot oh that changes every
day it's funny right now I'm relearning
all my lines because I'm getting ready
to play Hamilton in Puerto Rico the one
that's really fun for me that I'm proud
of right now because I'm relearning it
is um farmer refuted where Hamilton is
literally rhyming at the same time as
Samuel Seabury while he's verbally
destroying it that's pretty fun to play
I'm much more Zen about rejection
because now I've been on the other side
of the auditioning table and I realize
how little of it has to do with your
talent and how much of it has to do with
the very specific needs of that casting
director and that director in that
moment and so you can't take it
personally because you might be the
wrong height you might have for the
wrong hair color and and then the other
thing I will tell people is that you
have to think of auditioning as the job
it's not getting the job auditioning is
the job if you get the job great
but auditioning is actually the done
know I told that all I remember I rhymed
it with my uncle he's a janitor that was
one where the creators of the show
basically wrote and then Lin does an
incredible rhyme an incredible 16 bars
about Canada and rhymes it perfectly and
left it up to me to write so that was a
fun assignment it was it was really fun
I love those guys
[Music]
oh I'm as messed up and broken inside as
everybody else but I am well aware
just like you publishers that you get
what you put out into the world so I try
when I'm tweeting which is a terrible
addiction of mine
to just sort of try to put out what I
would like to see I did the same news
articles as you I you see the same
horrors I wake up with the same morning
breath
but I try if I'm having a terrible day
not to put the terrible out into the
world that make sense
these puppies were provided by
Vanderpump dogs and you can't hear
because they're chewing my mic record if
for more information on these beautiful
puppies go to vanderpump at dogs don't
work hi guys i'm hayley Steinfeld and i
am going to be answering some fan
questions with these adorable puppies
[Music]
I love the idea of playing a young yes
they agree they already they've heard
this answer quite a few times um a young
female character who is just this normal
girl but is brave and strong and smart
and just capable of the world this film
has a lot in it
a lot that I think transformers fans of
the previous films will enjoy and love
and appreciate this film has so much
heart so much love and laughter and it's
very character-driven it's got a lot in
it that I think you'll like
I would transform into a puppy so that I
could be a part of this this
[Music]
so a full album I actually had every
intention on putting it up on top this
year but this movie bumblebee
sort of came into the picture and a show
called Dickinson that I'm currently
working on and we'll be finishing up in
the new year and once that's done ow
I will be finishing what I started on
the music front so it's all in the works
and I can't wait to can't wait to tell
you oh it depends depends on what the
song is about who it's about I have uh I
have a handful of my closest friends
that I'll play my songs for and of
course my parents kind of sense so I've
been listening to a wide variety music I
feel like I always am with bumblebee the
film takes place in the 80s and has an
incredible eighties soundtrack so I've
got to immerse myself in that world of
music for a while one second please and
I love pop music so I listen to pop
music every single day and currently
Christmas music duh I feel like Dan
Keaton came to mind but Zach
Galifianakis also came to mine dream
music collaboration um he's not gonna
think I'm serious but it's it's the
truth
honey Blanco for Fanny barranco if you
will whoa Emily jump
she's worth giving a call right find out
where she is um Emily junk I would
assume she is like the head of a new
social club
I'm sure she's doing a lot of writing
probably just living life to the fullest
probably hasn't stopped smiling since we
last saw her I would absolutely return
for pitch perfect for I know that when
we were doing the third one we spoke
about you know where the heck would we
go from here maybe space maybe we're all
for and mothers by the next pitch
perfect who knows but yes I would love
to be a part of it
[Music]
Esther Dean Cynthia Rose she never fails
to make me laugh
and think she could figure out some way
to get us off
[Music]
under-eye concealer like game-changing
life-changing a holiday tradition
honestly for me a holidays are all about
being with family and eating a ton of
food the last couple of years I've been
on the road so we've created new
traditions in the last couple of years
just because you know wife life holds
different things for age each year so
I'm just being with my family having a
little bit of time off and lots of food
is involved too always 2019 well there
is so much in store for 2019 I am very
excited about my music that has been in
the works like I said for a while and a
long time coming so looking forward to
to that I can't wait for fans to see
this movie I bets at the end of this
year but we'll see where where that
leads us into the next year but music
travel fans performing all that I am
very much looking forward to 2019 these
tiny little babies were provided by
Pacific pups rescue and for more
information you can go to Pacific pups
rescue dot-com
[Music]
[Music]